[Music]
sh
he
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
Bo
oh
[Music]
he's down piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar's going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move checkmate
oh my God what an arm we get
in high stakes matches today four
biggies in the elimination bracket two
will be knocked out the drama is about
to begin welcome everyone to the
chessable Masters I'm International
Master t s alongside me there's no chess
with our grandm H and the ever brilliant
Grandmaster David how guys we've got a
big day ahead of us Robert loving the
pink chair what are you most hyped about
today well I mean can we predict any
more upsets because that would be
something special yesterday was a day of
the underdog Alicia Keys would be very
proud it feels like the stakes are
higher than ever there's more on the
line and as Tanya you mentioned two
players will leave it's not just any two
players those players in the elimination
bracket now four of the world's best so
there's definitely going to be blood
spiled I can't wait the action the four
players in the elimination any one of
them could be the tournament winner
they're that strong we'll Deep dive more
into that but first let's check out the
dates for this year's 2024 Champions
Chester four regular events leading up
to the tour and in-person live finals in
December we're in the chessable Masters
mark your calendars the four winners of
each of these four events will qualify
for the December finals and Robert also
the ever important door standings the
players are feeling the pressure they
certainly are because from the GetGo
you're looking how many points am I
going to gain from this performance if I
don't in fact win this section so these
players they know what's at stake a lot
of money and only four events this year
compared to six a season
ago fewer events the pressure is on and
the pressure was on yesterday as well
what an exciting start it was few would
have predicted the the winners the way
the games went yesterday and if you're a
fan of the story of The Underdogs
yesterday was a
blockbuster the play-ins the placements
they were super exciting but here we go
we have lifted off it is the CH this
time it's the white king that's running
up the board both Kings have been doing
a bit of dancing here but the white king
is doomed no way to escape you step fors
F5 there's going to be a deadly check on
F3 and uh White has to lose even more
material Yan pom she smiles and he's
about to resign Chas reacts he gets the
dub massive massive drama on the Wesley
board as Wesley gets flagged robber what
happened can he give a Petro check if
not black promotes and wins Rook to D7 a
blunder black deflects the rook and wins
the game is over fedos takes it what a
defensive F by him Jos B is about to
take this Victory we saw Yan pishi just
smile again shake his head Jose Martinez
is on a roll he has a super superpower
and he knows how to use it he has a low
rating and this is for everyone out
there at home if you're playing someone
higher rated you can just play solid you
can bully them and uh use it against
them and then we see resignation Dennis
wins it incredible Chess By
[Music]
Dennis it was a day of celebrations
three under 2700 players have made it
through to division one of the chel
Masters and they remain in the winners
bracket start with eight players on
Friday we see four go down into the
losers bracket meanwhile Dennis Las Vick
Magnus
Carlson Vladimir fedos continue their
run in to the winners bracket they will
be fighting it out but before that we've
also got the action coming in from the
losers bracket where we've got four
Heavy Hitters Maxim VRA takes on yanomi
wesy so will take on Ali rzza fuja big
fight David who impressed you the most
on day one of The Knockouts well there
wasn't any of those four players in the
elimination bracket the losers bracket
unfortunately I'm going to go instead
however for those underdogs Dennis
lazovic and Jose Martinez just uh
showing that being the underdog having
their opponents push harder trying to
take them down and kind of showing them
maybe a little less respect than they
deserve uh it has worked in their favor
and especially for young Dennis lazovic
nerves are still undefeated yesterday in
five games including an Armageddon
against Maxi Vash it was just a
fantastic
display of
solidity and there we have it Dennis
against Maxim four draws in the rapid
the Armageddon the Frenchman never
really got a chance and never got his
opportunity with the white pieces Dennis
lavic kept it solid we've got their
postm stats Robert what stands out to
you in this one it's the accuracy from
the youngster he is such a solid Style
he avoids really heavy mistakes but
what's interesting to note is down at
the bottom there it was Dennis lazik who
actually had a blunder in one of the
games but it didn't matter because when
it came down to it he only needed a draw
in Armageddon he did not need to win the
game so the blunders they weren't real
they were not found and that is why
Dennis lazic he moved on with that
Stellar play yeah and I've noticed he's
just so good with these armagon we also
saw that in the Toronto finals of the
previous season we saw that in the match
play when he took down Anish K and then
yesterday against Maxim he managed to
get the black pieces he outsmarted him
in the bids and then never gave him the
chance another player who never gave his
opponent a chance was Jose Martinez
playing against the two-time world
championship Challenger Yan Nai Yan a
big favorite on paper but David to my
eyes it just felt that Yan was
completely out of form
yesterday right we saw Yan Nom Nishi not
show show his best a blunder in one of
the early games and there was simply no
way back Jose was too solid too strong
after that and uh took his chances when
they came Martinez he's a man in form he
was so impressive during the play-ins as
well and uh this time format 10 minutes
on the clock two second increment really
seems to suit him uh so yanomi he will
hopefully step through the gears today
he needs to in that losers bracket but
Jose Martinez one to watch he's
definitely definitely uh the man of the
moment so far
Yi one of the four players on their last
lives today in the elimination bracket
for Jose Martinez it has been the
Cinderella story so far on his 25th
birthday he convincingly wins the Swiss
playin then goes on to book his spot in
division one Robert what impressed you
the most about Jose
yesterday pretty much everything his
composure the fact that when he gets in
time trouble he proves why he's a main
state of the bullet Chess Championship
year in and year out he's won a number
of the bullet brawls he's a streamer a
content creator sure but he's also an
exceptional player and a very strong
Grand Master just because he doesn't
venture to over the board tournaments
that can be expensive for many players
does not mean that he doesn't pack a
powerful punch and he's able to deliver
in those waning seconds because he is
that strong he is that strong and one
other player who is super strong and he
needs no introduction at all of course
he continues his run in the winnner
bracket it is Magnus gson who won his
match against Wesley so and today he
will take on Vladimir fedos it's the big
fish versus the biggest fish David what
are we expecting from this one where
does fedf create his chances against
Magnus Carlson well he simply has to
look to the other underdogs for
inspiration all of these lower rated
players rising up but also he is a
confident man fed remember the world
rapid Championship as recently as the
end of December feder got the silver
medal yes Magnus got gold but he knows
on his day he can hang with the best and
uh actually for Magnus Carson this is
not going to be a walkover FV has had a
few uh kind of games where he has been
successful against Magnus in the past uh
so both players if they bring their best
it's going to be a close fight and one
of those famous examples is when Magnus
Carlson a few years back he was trolling
coming onto chess.com trying to take
over the number one rating in Blitz and
you know who stopped him the big fish
Vladimir fedos said not so fast my
friend and he took him down he was every
bit his equal in that Blitz match this
is rapid it's different type of show but
the best part of fedos is he bends but
he does not break he is super
resourceful as he showed yesterday
against fuja yeah what a match that was
that's quite a comeback victory for
fedos he lost the first game and then
finally winning in the last round took
the match scored two wins in those best
of four Vladimir fedos has to bring in
the same form he has to bring in is his
aame as he faces the three time and the
reing door Champion fed have continues
the run in the winners bracket and it's
not just him we've got another another
big matchup uh in the winners bracket as
Dennis uh lazovic will be fighting it
out against jpim as well now while these
guys still have two lives left there are
four players who are on their last life
and two names that I think would
surprise everyone and few would have
predicted at the start Wesley so against
Ali are one of them will be eliminated
today now looking at their form coming
in from day one what do we make of this
matchup and is there a favorite in this
one
Robert oh this is a tossup but players
with very different styles what we tend
to appreciate at Wesley so super solid
ala fuja he makes chaos happen he's kind
of like the Joker and he is willing to
shake things up so this is a huge Clash
of styles a clash of generations I do
not know who to pick cuz a year ago they
both had four division one appearances
it proves that they are both Mighty and
hard to take
down a clash of styles a clash of
generations David this is going to be a
fun one what do you think will be the
key factor the key decisive factor in
this matchup just about who can get
their style of play Going On The Board
as Robert mentioned uh fuja he's the
agent of chaos all hell breaks loose uh
when he plays these days it's been up
and down win loss that was the story of
his tournament yesterday today as well
uh but for Wesley so if he can quiet
down the game if he can change the pace
uh maybe go into slower grindy endgame
type of positions then Wesley will stand
great chances but judging on yesterday's
form FIA wants that fire on the board um
so the games are going to be fascinating
no matter what yeah it's going to be a
lot about who gets their kind of
position whenever there's a clash of
styles so much depends on how the
opening progresses into the middle game
which player is more comfortable with
the kind of structures that appear on
the board it's going to be a fun battle
with high stakes but that's not the only
one our other big U match in the
elimination bracket as Maxim Vash lra
takes on Yan neishi both players lost on
day one they are on their last life and
one of them will I want to say go home
but they are playing from home but they
will get eliminated from the chessel
Masters um now to me these two players
of course two of the best players in the
world but they were just both off Maxim
never got his kind of positions against
Dennis lavic Dennis always kept it under
control what does he need to do today
against Yan Nei both very Dynamic
players both very Dynamic players Maxim
maybe just needs to use all of his
opening uh Weaponry his arsenal of these
fantastically kind of pinpointed opening
prep but uh Yan he's a bit of a moving
Target these days especially online uh
it just depends what mood he's in quite
often so um as you say t it's about who
of this 1990 generation a kind of clash
of the 33 year olds who comes into it
hotter I actually feel the first player
to win the game win a game here will uh
just cruise through I think uh both
players at this point they're just a bit
Restless they're just ready and um yeah
I don't think either is in the right
mindset to uh kind of bounce back if yet
another kind of setback happens so it's
going to be fascinating to watch I think
Vash Gra was a bit more solid yesterday
but who knows Yan is
capable and Yan is ready to go as we see
him on the camera he better be ready to
go with the players on their last life
and David you're absolutely right there
is no margin for error in the losers
bracket it's a best of two you lose one
game it's so difficult to come back with
just one more game left so they've got
to keep things under control and Yan
looks very amused right now well it's
because he knows how the horse he moves
apparently and you see y pomi all smiles
at the moment but when it's game time he
is serious yesterday was not his day he
was said instead focused on Twitter
rather than on the chest today he has to
go right back to the board against Maxim
vasher lrav someone he knows very well
in fact when y pom won his first
candidates he overtook Maxim those two
were neck and neck in the first half of
that delayed candidates tournament so
these two have history for yand pomi he
does not want history from yesterday to
repeat himself he wants to continue here
in division
one it's a big big match up coming up
Yan taking on Maxim V lra while earlier
on Twitter it looked like the two were
friendly right now David all friendship
has to be kept off the board it is all
Focus the gloves have to come off the
players high pressure right now what do
you think is going to be the opening
approach in this one for
Yan so better to leave that Twitter sesh
to one side for now um I feel that Yan
it depends right he's got the candidates
on the horizon he doesn't really want to
show off his best openings but if he
does employ his best openings uh the
Spanish with white you know the Petro
with black all of his kind of um yeah
his kind of aame U kind of openings then
I actually feel he has a chance but yeah
the players when they freestyle anything
can happen it's so hard to predict that
smile on the face as well it was there
throughout yesterday it seemed to
distract him he wasn't fully focused
Sayan and both players smiling and yeah
really rare to see this mindset it's
just about who settles in quicker um
this 10-minute time format traditionally
might favor Maxim Vash lra he's super
quick super instinctive yesterday Yan
was kind of yet to find his rhythm but
um I'm not making a prediction Tanya I'm
not brave enough how about
you yeah it's gonna be tough to predict
this one David Robert and David you
mentioned this time format 10 minutes
with a 2C increment very different from
last year where the players started with
15 minutes and 3 second increment at
this level how much of a difference is
that 1 second what does how does that
change the Dynamics for these players
David massive especially when the clocks
tick down um the players at some point
will reach that climax of the game when
it's really messy when the tactics are
flying and uh there it's just pure
Instinct so two seconds disappears
instantly we even saw Wesley so lose on
time yesterday that's how quickly the
increment can disappear and uh both of
these players known for their speed they
don't really want to get down to those
time scrambles and usually it's just
about who's in the better shape who's in
better form here we go though it is the
Petro defense uh one that I named
dropped earlier showing how much yand
pesi wants to win this game he's taking
it seriously this tournament the Chester
ball Masters he wants to win it we see a
trade of Pawns in the center this is
still the main line of the Petro defense
until now not the most common move white
bringing out a bishop blocking the D
Pawn but this D Pawn will later most
most likely move often white pushes the
pawn forward drops the bishop back and
then the D Pawn is free so clearly
preparation a bit of a battle here we
see on the left side of our boards um
the percentages of the U the kind of
outcome of this opening white tends to
win 47% of the time that's a huge score
I've got to say uh but yand pomi he's
got more time in the tank Robert what do
you make of these early moves these
early decisions I'm honestly most
surprised by Maxim ver gr's time usage
he's one of the quickest players on the
planet as is yand pami and we are seeing
a pawn sacrifice in the moment so white
is about to take twice goes up a pawn
black gets a pair of Bishops on an open
board so that is compensating for the
material deficit but as I look just at
the clock Yan Naomi in his preparation
it was Maxim who played an offbeat
opening and Tanya are you as a surpris
as I am to see that it's Maxim playing
something of a sideline and yet he's the
one using his clock
definitely and Robert we've spoken so
much about preparation and this is that
something that has to be y's World
Championship prep but for maxim he's
still in the think with that last move
so I'm just trying to understand there
are so many natural developing moves
here you can take the Knight out to C3
you could double up on the E Line
attacking the bishop what goes on in a
grandmaster's mind at this early stage
when obvious moves are in front of you
to slow down what is Maxim thinking
about here David Maxim he's the most
instinctive player I've ever met I've
played him since we were both 8 years
old and normally in a position like this
he would kind of throw the moves down
the board they'd be flying out Pawn to
D3 like you said bring the bishop out
bring the Knight out he won't stop to
calculate until it's really necessary
but he knows he's walked into some
opening preparation here and hence his
last move he's trying to simplify the
equation um that is not yand pishi I can
confirm that is Wesley so on the camera
unless uh Something Magic has happened
but uh yeah he's just trying to get rid
of a set of Pawns trying to simplify the
equation since he is one Pawn ahead um
but Robert's right uh the time usage is
really mysterious I have actually seen
yand ponesi employ this Pawn sacrifice
in the past it is known so Maxim may be
surprised by the employment of the Petro
defense uh maybe just didn't spend too
much time preparing wanting to stay
fresh instead either way he's getting
out of the opening and once white
recaptures black also has an issue how
to develop these pieces if the black
bishops start playing then I do fear for
white despite the extra Pawn so Robert
how would you evaluate the Practical
chances of this Gambit the sacrifice
well this last decision to offer a trade
of Queens I think is a good practical
one from Maxim VRA we often tell our
newer members of the audience our
students to trade pieces when you're
ahead white is a pawn up so if the
Queens could come off the board and also
if the Rooks later leave then that extra
Pawn will make it presence felt it is a
C2 Pawn but later you can use it as a
pass Pawn push it forward so the Bishops
they are long range pieces they can poke
and prod on both flanks that's the good
news the bad news for Jan is he is down
upon and I don't see the clear-cut
compensation I don't see something he
can Target he is now playing defense a
bit he's going to prevent white from
pushing those pawns forward and the
queen trade has happened you see the
evaluation bar slightly inching upwards
for white I would agree with that
assessment I would certainly love to
have this it's a dream position for Mex
see yeah he's got the extra pawn and
David sorry but I was just going to say
p is traded off Queen's traded off he's
got the extra Pawn The Bishop's coming
out it just looks like Yan's going to be
fighting it out for a draw here it feels
like a game for two results to me I was
about to kind of preach about how you
should trade on your terms not your
opponent's terms I was really surprised
to see yand pishi take off that Queen in
the center a few moves ago because now
White's Knight is really well solidified
look at this it looks like a granite
statue in the middle of the board
protected by this Pawn protected by the
bishop it's on a square we call an
outpost and the only way to get rid of
it effectively is to trade off these
Knights but now if white does take the
Black Knight the black pawns will be
shattered I'm expecting that to happen
any moment now uh what else simply for
white the compensation here for black
will lie in this bishop being a bit of a
nasty pest here along the diagonal just
reminding the white pawns on the queen
side that they're slightly vulnerable
and this bishop if it can get into the
game if there is a trade of knights for
example by this diagonal then uh the
Bishops do start to play a role so still
not over but I agree with both of you at
the very minimum white should be able to
return a pawn and uh kind of bail out
into a draw so it's very much a two
result type of position where it's white
trying to make things happen trying to
cling on trying to profit from the extra
material but essentially black
objectively should be fine this is
really reminiscent of the Marshall
Gambit and other E4 E5 openings that
some of our viewers might know where
black gives up upon but has long-term
and and watch out for the B file to
become a bit of a pressure point in the
near future but for now these two
weaknesses do give black the questions
to answer white t night is
coming small Advantage I think we're all
in agreement here for white this the
first time for everything right we're
all agreeing white is better it's a safe
position the Knight as you mentioned can
venture to B3 and C5 or up to E4 into
the center and unfortunately for Jan he
has his own weaknesses to worry about a
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn David
you know I like to do this if you can
just grab that C6 pawn and Scoot it over
to B6 for a second well that looks like
a much more stable Foundation where your
pawns are connected but with the pawns
separated the way they are that means
that white can start attacking them in
fact the A7 Pawn already means that the
black Rook is tether to it you can't
easily move that into the position
because A7 will drop so the Bishops are
out Tanya we all seem to be on the same
page here but I guess the question
becomes how challenging will it be for
Jan to prove that he can up that half
Point yeah that's the that's the big
question here Yan will be on the defense
he's got the bishop bear and the open b
line and The Rook on the D file also on
the open file as compensation so there's
definitely peace activity but at the end
of it Maxim up upon the night having
these good squares I think Maxim going
to try to get as much as he can from
this position will try to grind it out
this is a good moment to jump back to
our other high stakes game which we
haven't had a look at um as Wesley so
takes on ala fuja one of these two
players will be eliminated should we
check in with our other two Heavy
Hitters let's do just that Tanya as we
see ala fuja starting with the white
pieces against Wesley so and uh I was
going to say Wesley so solid because
this is Rock Solid for black no
weaknesses at all it's what we call the
kpad pawn structure uh whenever we see a
pawns on E3 and D4 faced off by pawns on
C6 and D5 but with a Twist this time
because white has already advanced a
pawn to F4 pros and cons here you have
more central control but a bit of a back
with the pawn now the uh backward Pawn
on E3 is a bit tender you'll be stuck
defending it for a long time I've got to
say I'm surprised the evaluation bar is
uh kind of slightly in White's favor
here unless it's because of this move
opening up the center um I would have
thought black is doing completely fine
but suddenly questions to answer the
black queen is hit this is very Dynamic
now up for's Alley we're talking about
who wants their start of position of
game and white is suffering long term
white has a weak isolated Queen Pawn
this F4 Pawn very tender as well but for
now this queen hit the F6 Pawn a bit of
a Target as well um Robert you're great
with these tactics do you see any
trouble here for Wesley so is if he just
Retreats his Queen for example is he
still as solid as it looks at first
glance well white is going to start
throwing pieces forward especially if
that Queen goes to C7 away from the
black king I think F5 is the next move
that Ali Rea wants to uncork let's open
up that diagonal for the queen to land
on H6 let's go for tactics in front of
the black king So for Wesley the long
term is great for him white has this
isolated Pawn that is blockaded if the
queen disappeared oh white is in some
danger in the long run the end game
would be one that Kappa Blanca could
only dream of may he Rest In Peace So as
I look at his position I think it
actually plays to both of these player
Styles in the immediate position white
can go on the prowl go for the black
king but if you stall if you head state
for even a moment and black is able to
further consolidate and solidify the
position there are some longterm
weaknesses so F5 is in the board Tanya I
think that uh it's a battle of styles
here and both players are doing the
right
thing I completely agree with everything
that you've just said but I do like
White's position especially after that
move F5 and to complete your thought if
we just back up before Knight to D5 was
played David as black you really want to
keep things closed and you want to keep
your king side solid but I think the
tactics that you were pointing out
earlier if black does make the move like
G5 they're already on the board because
after G5 white can go Knight takes F6
pick up that pawn on F6 and suddenly
Queen takes G5 once you recapture the F6
Knight Falls and the whole King side
falls apart so there's really no way for
Wesley to keep the king side blocked
which means that the white Bishop on D3
and the pawn on F5 can open up after a
trade in the live on the live board and
I see the G6 Pawn indeed has been traded
off I think this position suits Ali
razar Style just a little bit more than
it suits
Wesley I think David might uh be muted
right now as we could see him chatting
but nothing said David you back with
used about the
position I was just saying that um this
position I like it for white as well I'm
on T's side it looks very attractive for
fua but he has to keeping it's like
riding a bicycle if you stop you might
fall off and uh longterm because he is
worse here he is kind of suffering with
this backward de Pawn this isolated Pawn
um longterm chances aren't great he has
to play for the attack so key moment
he's stopped he's thinking he's actually
quite significantly down on the clock
but moved like Queen to H6 strikeout
look really really attractive at some
point you might consider throwing
battering round the board with your H
Pawn if Wesley's able to trade off
pieces Wesley will be loving life watch
out for Wesley for example bring the
black queen forward and offering that
trade so very much in the balance as we
see this real Clash of styles both
players playing true to their character
here really fascinating
watch yeah and I think it's a kind of
position where if the pieces get traded
off like you're pointing out with Queen
to F4 these longterm weaknesses that
white has the isolated Queen Pawn on D4
these will come into play and give a
black give Wesley chances to perhaps
fight for more so for alira it's really
key to try to make most of the
initiative on the king side I love the
idea of putting the queen on 86 Robert
how can actually ala try to keep the
Queens on the board because now that I
see Queen H6 Queen F4 actually forces a
queen trade and that is certainly not
what ala wants so he's trying to make
this Checkmate happen but you can't will
it into existence and that's the problem
especially for newer players who love to
try to deliver a Checkmate you think I'm
going after the opponent's king I'm
going to Checkmate them and then they
just trade the Queens off and you feel a
little bit lost like you don't have any
chest left in you and so for aldera here
comes the queen trade he's strong enough
where of course he he doesn't feel at a
loss he is great in the end game as well
but as I look at the clocks and I look
at the position I have to say Advantage
Wesley so he has been able to Stave off
that first wave of attack he's in good
shape and with the pieces coming off I
really don't see the problem for black
anymore looks great for black I've got
to say um I'm going to revise my opinion
just from one move ago or two moves ago
now that the Queens have left the only
Solace for white is that you have access
to this D6 Square the White Knight does
jump in so the trade of the Queens
longterm again great for black but
shortterm white is hitting uh this Pawn
white is trying to cause some nuisance
now infiltrating potentially on the
seventh rank will The Rook jump in again
you have to play active you have to play
dynamically to keep the momentum uh
before you fall off that bike and uh in
the meantime threats black threatening
to take this Knight maybe threatening to
take this porn as a deflection but yeah
playing energetically as predicted
hitting this night evaluation bar
stubbornly in the middle who's uh just
before we switch back to the other game
whose position do we feel is easier to
play now that the Queens are
off I would say I would say White's
activity now is speaking to me but
Black's position is better but in The
Other Board we see a rook trade on offer
between Maxim Vash L and yand pomi on
the left and this is a critical moment
in that game because if Jan trades Rooks
he better have calculated 15 moves ahead
as his pwn structure is weaker so this
is one of these end games on the left
hand side of our screen here that we do
not take for granted it is pure
calculation if you're y a PM that's why
he's invested already over 30 seconds I
could see him thinking for another
minute but even if you don't trade Rooks
in this position you've still got to be
careful right because white king can try
and March over to D4 it just feels like
black spawn structure is so terrible on
that left side of our screen right now
so if anyone's trying to push this it's
got to be Maxim but David realistically
what are the chances with the Rook on
the board given Black's weaknesses is
there real metal to try in this
position unfortunately I think that
chances are minimal he's playing a great
defender in yanomi someone who'll defend
actively I really like Black's last move
on that left board on our screens
Black's pushing the hbor forward just
edging uh towards making yet another
trade the black king might March forward
to I think it's just too little material
it's h too reduced your artillery here
just no real winning chances if you were
playing someone lower rated maybe Maxi
Vash G would get excited but unlikely
against Yan also look at the clock times
in that left on that left board two
minutes against four I simply don't
think Vash Gra is going to uh be
anything at all a draw by far the most
likely result in that one uh even if
white is having slightly uh the better
of it symbolically so um yeah we're
predicting a draw on the left side of
the board in the meantime Wesley so has
frozen on the other one uh the white
Rook has landed on E7 and suddenly the
clock times have balanced out there
Robert you mentioned that um board clock
slightly favored Wesley uh are you still
of the same opinion after this long
think and then he makes a move oh but
this is actually a huge moment on the
right hand side of our screens because
Wesley so his Rook is the only piece
protecting his Knight so the White
Knight can put pressure on The Rook I
know this may be a bit difficult for
people to visualize but on the right
hand board the Knight can attack The
Rook to try to kick it but the black
king will step closer to the white Rook
that is what's holding on for Wesley so
he invested the time wisely and he's
worked it out you see the evaluation bar
still in the middle but actually on left
hand side of our screens the evaluation
bar is going up and up in that ma V L's
favor this isn't just a drawn end game
Maxim is
pushing commentator Tanya I might have
jinxed him there Maxim you asking about
winning chances maybe he's created some
it looks like he's just pushed his F
bond that defi weakness is forever there
black needs to trade on G3 but I'm still
thinking about the right side board that
we were pointing out the move Knight B7
that you mentioned earlier hitting that
Rook we might be seeing a repetition
with black king shuffling one step to
the left and one step to the right King
f8 King G8 just pursuing White's Rook on
the E7 87 Square Wesley so shaking his
head there but he's got nothing to be
worried about right now what are the
chances of these guys going in for the
repetition Right Here Right
Now the more that fua is in the tank the
more his clock drops down the more
inclined he will be towards failing out
with a draw you can escape here with
white you can force the issue and take a
draw if you want and we're seeing that
Motif happen on the right side of your
screen look at this the black king
stepping left stepping right hitting the
white rook and uh where to go no Escape
squares a trade of Rooks and actually
that will clearly favor Black so I think
this is the time for fuan to bail out
meantime in The Other Board the
evaluation bar has gone through the roof
suddenly is white winning Maxim Vash gra
is he going to win this Rook end game
fuja against so is indeed a draw by
repetition it's time to focus Maxi Vash
gra this end game he's working some
magic suddenly npom she leans back
realizes there's big trouble white C
Pawn is simply going to March up the
board how to stop this Simple Plan of
promoting the pawn what he missed
because as you said the carpet has been
rolled out for that c pawn and black is
down a pawn even though material is
equal let that sink in the material is
even both sides have two pawns but black
kind of has one and this is why double
pawns are so bad this is why your
coaches tell you you want to avoid it if
you can because one white pawn stops two
of blacks David I'm going to have you do
that thing again pick up the F7 Pawn for
a second just hover it or that one yes
to E6 you can create a pass Pawn you
can't do it when there are two Pawns in
a row like this and white on the other
hand play C4 C5 C6 and so on and it gets
the other
side really nicely explained there
Robert that essentially white has an
extra Pawn it's pushing forward and The
Rook on D5 is so nicely placed because
it makes sure that the black king can
never actually pass through and defend
that c Pawn from a queening it's
attacking the F5 Pawn it's blocking off
the D5 file and it looks like Yana pishi
is in big trouble easy moves for
white moves and he's calculated so well
here the mathematician Maxim Vash GRA
with that education he is so good in
these positions where it's just a race
white is marching forward not just that
but the once the white Pawn steps
forward the white Rook will actually
step behind to block any attempts by the
black Rook to give itself up and uh I'm
not sure if there's even any time to go
and grab this white Pawn he has to try
it because what else you have to take
that pawn and hope to get the black Rook
back but two squares away now and it
will be soon touchdown once the porn
lands on C7 it will be unstoppable the
shaking his head he knows it's
inevitable now he's let it slip what was
I I think commentator curs again I was
claiming a dead drawn endgame it's gone
five moves later he's busted that's how
difficult these end games are I need to
go back and study my Rook end games
that's for sure NP Mishi maybe just
rushing a bit he's still had a few
minutes left on his clock when he made
that mistake but fair play toas Gru
impressive smooth sailing we said it was
a two result game he squeezed water from
a stone here Maxim VRA felt it that
there was something to fight for in that
position where Yana pomi declined The
Rook trades it looked so close to a draw
but it all comes down to the pawn
structure he managed to create the pass
pawn and like you mentioned there's no
time for black to even grab the F4 Pawn
we've been talking about that Rook on D5
once the C PA moves forward that Rook on
D5 will slide one step towards the left
side and block any defensive ideas on
the sea line as well the king and the
Rook playing an impressive role in
assisting the C Pawn this is Maxim Vash
lra's game he knows it he leans back and
the graph below the board tells the full
story here it was even and I think that
Yap pomi he was lulled into a sense of
complacency I'll make a draw every
single time I get this position not
today not now and the problems were with
his Pawn structure he had these split
pawns and this D5 Pawn in particular was
a weakness and now it's off the board
only white has a passer Black's King
it's slowly marching towards the side of
the board white can even give up The
Rook to get a new Queen but I'm not sure
if that's necessary like why don't you
just bring your Rook to the final Rank
and then push your Pawn after it just
don't give black even a semblance of
Hope here queen versus Rook is a win
theoretically speaking but when you
don't have much time on your clock it
can difficult to prove so I like keeping
the Rook on the board and then pushing
the
pawn Rob The Profit again he drops his
Rook back the pawn is going to promote
not much to do about it uh the pawn will
cost the black Rook his life Tanya I
think we'll see a resignation any moment
now yes absolutely I think Yana pami
knows it as well the king is extremely
strong strong on B5 and just marches
forward to assist that C7 Pawn The Rook
on D3 making sure that the black king
can't come and defend that C8 Square
pieces are beautifully placed and notice
how black still hasn't even managed to
create a pass paa and that is it Yi
cannot fight the C7 Pawn he resigns
Maxim takes the win wow this end game
just turned around really fast rob it it
did and that's what happens when you
think that you're for sure going to make
a draw I don't blame Yan pomi on a good
day he draws that game for sure but not
in this one Maxim Vash never G gave up
he was ceaselessly determined to fight
for the full point and he earned
it he earned it and we can see the shock
on yanami he knows it he was so close to
holding this with the black pieces this
is our score line going into the final
game of the elimination bracket yamna
pishi has to win on demand or it will be
the end of the road for him in the
cherel Masters meanwhile Wesley saw
alira fuja after quite an exciting
battle there in the opening the middle
game G it ended peacefully with a draw
David this end game I'm still thinking
about it what was the turning around the
turnaround moment there that you felt
for
white I think uh it was just uh Maxim
Vash gra applying a little pressure
setting this trap deep in the end game
and Yan Nomi falling into it um it was
actually simply a case of yan relaxing
as uh Robert mentioned if he just
protected his all important Central Pawn
if he' activated the black king bit
earlier then it would have been a very
different story it should have been a
relatively simple draw but um yeah never
relaxing rooking games always think
about what the opponent wants think
about the opponent trying to trick you
Yan his guard simply wasn't up and in
Rapid chess that is brutal opponents are
ruthless and we saw it there one move
and he was done that
was and now for y p he has to get over
it there is no time to recover only one
rapid game remaining me S he must win on
demand meanwhile of course for Wesley so
alira fua it remains level and they've
got to fight it out in the next one what
are the chances of this matchup going
into the Armageddon Robert I think very
high because Wesley so doesn't take
tremendous risk if he doesn't have to
right if he's down a point and needs to
win he'll go all in but he drew game one
he has a ton of experience in Armageddon
from the Champions chess tour a year ago
and as we see a Kings Pawn opening from
both sides the big question will we get
an Italian game oh the answer is yes
instead of a Berlin and he is trying to
outmaneuver Ala later on so I do think
that this is Wesley style oh but he is
playing this trendy line uh we've seen
it a lot and you see to the left of the
board white does win uh quite a handful
of times but black wins his fair share
too my big question here is whether
Alisa FIA has done his homework Wesley
actually employed this opening yesterday
against Magnus Carson when he was behind
in the match and needed a win with white
and fuja here acting very quickly and
differently to uh Magnus in that game
yesterday uh so often you need to keep
an eye on what your opponent's been
doing in recent times you need to
prepare you need to have an idea up your
sleeve fuja here dropping the black
Bishop back I'm just waiting it's
something you referred to yesterday
Robert just for the chaos button Pawn to
G5 for that to be Unleashed yes it kicks
back the white Bishop but it also
weakens the black king so really
double-edged type of position and uh I'm
really glad I've got to say first of all
we're seeing the Italian not the Berlin
I was dreading it I thought oh straight
to Armageddon but no this one bubbling
nicely as there we go G5 on the
board this is definitely a bubbling up
and will'll explode after that last move
G5 it's a lot about the blink first game
in these openings both sides wait for a
castle uh from their opponent before
deciding to go G5 but in this position
Ali Resa does it with Wesley's King
still in the center and what are the
chances especially after that last move
that we're going to see Ali razar's king
castle on the other side of the board is
he looking for safety on the queen side
in an Ideal World yes but that's uh the
nature of this opening where it's hard
to make that work because there are
these pawns for white already pushed on
the queen side the A4 Pawn is extended
quite far and the C3 Pawn helps white
push B4 next and eventually to B5 so I
think the black king is safest in the
center for now until white makes his
intentions clear and only then will you
decide where your Castle it could still
be the king side many players do that
especially if the white king heads there
first just as say he says it he play as
you say it he plays it Robert and now it
feels far safer for black to commit to
this side of the board now you know your
opponent's intentions no commitment
issues there for Wesley at least he gets
the white king to safety but fua he's
actually going on a bit of a night dance
here the Black Knight wants to retreat
come around and sit on a really nice
perge not just defending the king side
in case he wants to Castle there but
also getting ready to push these black
horns down the board now that he knows
his opponent's intentions watch out for
this diagonal as well Black's Bishop a
raking piece from afar and uh this is
going to be mutual attacks white
advancing on the queen side black most
likely advancing on the other flank and
there we see a blue arrow that wasn't me
that was the computer saying Black's
best move by far is Knight to f8 so I'm
expecting that move to be played there
we go the players clearly within their
homework a bit of home cooking here and
I can't wait to see this Pawn March down
the board for better or worse Black is
all in for the attack
now and the speed with which the players
are playing it clearly implies that
they're still in preparation right now
that last move Bishop to D5 avoiding any
trade you're pointing out the H Pawn
moving forward white will have to tackle
the threat of that Bishop on G3 getting
trapped which means that he have to push
his own H Pawn forward and very often
it's to H4 to make sure that black has
to take a decision with that g Pawn
either you close it with G4 or you try
to open up the G file I think we might
see a structure with H5 H4 and black
pushing
G4 you're very very likely to be correct
here Tanya um I've spent way too many
hours of my life analyzing this type of
position and that usually does happen
here we go first step of the plan big
threat on the board trying to trap this
bishop it's got no squares pushing a
pawn to H3 is simply too timid give
black a free hand to choose which Pawn
to push black will blow open the
position on his terms so why not fix the
structure or at least ask the question
on your own terms and uh this is what
Wesley needs to go for um I'm trying to
recall my memory is getting up getting
worse as I get older but I'm pretty sure
I studied this exact position before and
H4 is the best move but uh we'll see
what Wesley has in store as Robert
mentioned the Italian game there's so
many ways to play it you can put your
own personal stamp on these lines but
style-wise to my eyes at least this is
going to favor alaza if both players are
on their own he prefers this type of
position over Wesley that is 100% true
and your memory does serve you well if
my memory serves me well because I do
believe that H4 as you and Tanya both
just mentioned is the response that
white needs to play Here and After G4
well then the difficult decisions
continue to arise because you hop
forward to go for the attack but your
knight could get trapped in enemy
territory if we just show this variation
the pawn often could push up to F6 and
your knight has nowhere to go it can
continue jumping into the position but
that's the last stop on the Knight tour
because the Rook slides up to H7 you're
getting ready to take or try to play
Move Like Bishop E6 first to win that
knight uh for without giving material
back so uh just to point out the Knight
often Retreats rather than hops forward
and if that's the case white will step
his own King into the corner play Pawn
to F3 and blow the whole position open
so I don't know who King is safer I
don't know what to make of it I've seen
positions like this before and they are
always just crazy and chances for both
sides this one like to see yes it's
exactly what we like to see and I think
we're going to see this one blow up
meanwhile the other game that needs to
blow up for Yan pesi is his one against
Maxim and uh I think it's a good moment
to check in with them because look at
what we've got on the board is
definitely started from a sicilian and
now the fight for the D5 square that
last move Knight to G8 it surprises me
and looks like at least from the eval
bar that yanami is on his way to make a
comeback Robert this last move Knight G8
given a cross a Miss by our harsh game
review but uh yeah it's just an ugly
position I think no good choices there
for black look at this pin it's ugly the
White Knight beautiful even if you just
cement that Knight with a move like Pawn
to C4 um I was black ever going to break
this bind looks beautiful for white well
when we have a Miss I do think it's
important to show everybody what was the
improvement over this and it wasn't
actually pretty for black so this this
decision was made out of several badl
looking op if you take this Knight on D5
with say your F Knight after the pawn
takes back there is a little Fork the
bishop has to take because the Knight on
E7 is pinned and now this is where loose
pieces drop off so I do think there's a
tactic that starts with Bishop takes
Pawn on G6 uh because the bishop on D5
is loose you take my Bishop back great
for you I will take your knight first
step and then take your B B on D5 and I
know we just went down a deep variation
but this is what's going on in these
players heads and what Maxim is
suggesting is that this position is
beyond hope for black the engine doesn't
hate it but practically speaking white
controls all of the key squares in the
middle of the board namely the light
squares so you have a knight that can
occupy light Square in addition the
Queen the bishop it can't do anything
about it it's on the dark Square it's
inherently stuck to its color complex
this is an overwhelming Advantage for
white I think practically speaking white
wins a position like this a healthy uh
majority of the time and that's why Max
te said look I'll play a passive move
just to avoid making Jan's life as clear
as possible I think it's a good try in a
bad position I I think Tanya that no one
would want to play this position from
Maxim shoes really well explained there
I think from a practical perspective
what Maxim has done he's kept maximum
number of pieces in the board it also
gives white the opportunity to go wrong
but the other position that we saw with
all the trades and the good knight wors
his bad Bishop all the weaknesses for
maxim Maxim would have been on the
defensive side and I'm just thinking
about the fact that this looks like it
came from some sort of a night off that
became a hybrid with a dragon now the
night off is Maxim's bread and butter
how did he manage to get into so much
trouble early on in something that he's
a big big expert
in the problem for maxim and I liked
your maximum P Tanya the problem for
maxim is he's employed the nidor but
that was also The Stomping Ground of
yanomi for most of his career we're
seeing the two biggest world experts in
the current age at least of the nof the
Sicilian nof and unfortunately if your
opponent knows just as much as you do
they also know what openings you fear
what variations are the most testing
most tricky and look at this blowing
open the king side now this is a pawn
Sacrifice by yand ponesi but he's
zeroing in on this black king he knows
that this is a big Target open lines are
the currency of this position who cares
about pawns the fewer pawns you have the
more open lines you have and uh this
black king now in huge huge trouble not
much to do if you slide your Bishop back
it will simply get traded off this
Defender and if the black Bishop
disappears then black is doomed on the G
file so many targets lined up and look
at the body language uh Robert Maxim
just hating his life uh questioning his
life decisions with Sicilian night here
I don't know about his life but I hate
his position and while he is in the
think tank trying to figure out a way
out of this I think we should go back to
our two board view because it's not just
this game that has fireworks the other
one
we knew it was coming it was brewing but
now it's reached that point where we
look at the right hand side of our
screen it's Ali Raza fua whose time in
this tournament is on the line the
advantage according to the evaluation is
in White's favor and I think it's easy
to explain so why don't we dive in
quickly to Wesley so with the white
pieces against Ali Rea because Wesley
he's on the door of eliminating this
candidate in fuia because the Knight on
the rim is dim and I'm not talking about
the Knight on H4 which snagged the pawn
I'm talking about that Knight on A5
that's trapped over there and White's
last move it hits a bishop yes but it
also shuts down any possibility of
defending the Knight if the bishop saves
itself Queen up to B4 and I think Tanya
it's pretty clear that that Knight on
the rim it's not dim any longer it's
gone I'm just looking at this line that
you're pointing out and it actually just
feels like that Knight on A5 drops alira
is going to be down a piece so what is
it that he wants and only one thing
makes sense to me is that he wants wants
to go all out on the king side he wants
to start pushing his Pawn he's going to
try and come for Wesley's King clearly
the evalar or the evil bar in this case
for alira seems to say the plan isn't
working but let's say if white was to
force this line Bishop goes back you can
capture the Knight on H4 or go directly
either ways either the Knight will fall
back or the queen will fall back and
Knight G6 here you take on A5 black
starts going H4 it at least starts to
get a bit messy on the king side with
White's Queen on the other end of the
board and maybe David you will help me
follow up with the attack like you're
showing the queen moves forward the G
Pawn pushing forward this is far from
over you're up material but you might be
down a king if you're not careful on the
king
side uh certainly slightly deceptive the
evaluation bar we now know that white
should be winning with best play if you
find all the best defensive moves for
example here maybe Pawn to F4 due to a
nice little skewer on the the fifth rank
uh maybe you defend here but this is
rapid chess nerves involved high stakes
and uh so hard to evaluate for the
players I think both players will
probably guess that the evaluation bars
on white side but fuja is one of the
best in the world at just hustling
swindling his opponents and he goes for
it immediately not even caring about
this black Bishop he might even be down
two pieces this black Bishop might be
snacked on next the Black Knight might
disappear if the White Queen steps
forward to B4 but he's all in it's all
about the white king
and here we go it is a race material
versus the attack who is going to Wesley
playing super fast though with a couple
of minutes extra on the clock Robert it
just feels like too much now especially
with the dart Square Bishop gone as well
he's following our plans this line but
do you this attack being successful how
easy is is it for Wesley to blunder here
no I don't see the huge attack that ala
is hoping for and there's also a Pawn on
A7 so if you can imagine the White Queen
Landing next to the Rook on the last
rank if as long as that pawn survives it
actually remains a threat but talking
specifically about this moment here uh
ala he went for the attack he went for
an aggressive position from the black
side but that often does play to Wesley
so's favor he doesn't mind getting into
tactical positions if you're the one
initiating them often times from a
speculative decision so I think that
Wesley he's happy to be in this point he
knows that he has the upper hand he also
has more time than his opponent so what
move come to mind well the Knight on D2
is under attack right now I would even
think about giving up that Knight to win
that Knight on A5 Queen B6 for white
looks very attractive to my eyes because
black unfortunately can't combine
multiple ideas you want to both take the
Knight on D2 and push your Pawn to G3 to
trap that Bishop over there next to the
white king but you can't get away with
both and that's why I think Wesley is
just in time to keep everything
together David a really really exciting
position position this one down a piece
is Wesley going to spend some time
trying to defend this Knight on D2 or
will he go for Counterattack it's quite
a big moment and I think it's really
instructive how Wesley's paused right
now he knows this is critical he has to
try to make sure nothing happens on the
king side and then he's just up
materially he takes the win he takes the
match so really important for him and he
goes for your idea Robert he's not going
to waste time defending that Knight on
D2 and I kind of like this move even a
bit more than Queen to B6 simply because
it's got one more idea you're you're
attacking the Knight on E5 but also that
pawn on D6 whenever you can make a
multi-purpose move in chess you've got
to do it Queen B4 I like
it4 looks good double attack simply and
now fua simply has to back up those
earlier sacrifices he has to go for
Glory he played Pawn to G3 two problems
here firstly uh White can just allow
this bishop to drop white is already a
piece up actually that will be a double
agent for example at the very minimum if
say I take this Pawn say I just hide in
the corner now this black pawn keeps the
white king safe it's guarding white here
actually you want to pick up this pawn
and throw it off the board if you're
fuia but frustratingly in chess you
cannot do that white Knights will start
coming forward the black king is uh the
one in trouble here but if we go back to
the current position other Solutions
might involve just taking this Pawn off
the board look at this if you take this
Pawn Counterattack against the black
king suddenly and it becomes a pure race
I'm not sure how you fend off the attack
against the white king this has to be
worked out really really well but we see
the evaluation bar showing that White's
attack is the more dangerous of the two
I would be looking at Bishop takes Pawn
check here I'd be looking at moves like
Queen takes Pawn if you're not getting
checkmated black having threats of the
his own meanwhile it's still up in the
air but if you're careful we know that
Wesley is winning this is why he stopped
to calculate he senses the critical
moment and uh whichever he goes for
whichever move now uh taking the Knight
one of the options we mentioned he will
be confident that he's worked things out
so this move given AC cross a uh a Miss
but still Advantage white and I think
now he will slide the white king into
the corner and uh there we go he's given
a blue arrow the only good move use that
black porn as a shield but sufficient to
maintain
white uh Robert still super complicated
do you see the time uh situation playing
a critical role I think the time will
play a part just because from my eyes
white has his Pawn on A7 there are two
distinct threats taking on F7 with check
which just wins the house and queen to
B8 and oh my goodness I forgot that
black could Castle because that King was
in the center black was going for the
attack but castling actually took care
of both problems at the same time white
is still in the driver seat look at the
positioning of each respective King
Knight F3 I don't know if that was your
arrow it's probably saying it's the only
move that keeps the advantage for white
at this stage but it's also a very
natural move so I would prefer Wesley's
chances at this stage Tanya do you see
anything that would counter that
I'd love to find something for black
here trying to look for ways to
compensate for uh I'm just trying to do
the math here so how many pawns is that
with that pawn on A7 it makes it really
difficult White's got a Pawn on A7
Black's got a Pawn on H2 so even though
materially I believe this is balanced
but just simply what having the better
Pawn structure the better pieces Black's
King more exposed I love how Black's
Pawn on H2 is actually defending white
sking on H1 a black sking in danger it
just looks like despite not having m
Advantage Wesley's got all the play in
the position so completely agree with
you Robert that Ali Resa has to find a
way to save this one and it's not going
to be
easy my Works in that game but meanwhile
let's check out our other game where
things are really heating up it feels
like Wesley against alaza there will
take a Karma turn at least for the next
few moves but wow just on time a queen
sacrifice and check me coming F gra
resigns wow we will break that down for
you a bit later but NPI finishes off in
style and Strikes Back 1-1 Armageddon
guaranteed now the black king about to
be m in the next two uh wow we said it
it was oneway traffic black was
suffering on the king side R to see such
flamboyant checkmating patterns though
at this high level so congratulations to
Yan
pishi yeah how do you think he's feeling
now I mean this last position with Queen
takes that we see on the left side of
our screen this looks this looks like a
massacre that just happened but from
start to finish Yan was in driver seat
we got an armagon and the kind of games
that we've had the two decisive games
between these two we can expect a lot of
fireworks in that one but let's shift
our Focus onto Wesley versus Ali Raza
because big things are happening in that
one black has grabbed the C3 Pawn why
did just me the move that gets that gets
rewarded should I say with a question
mark and Ali going all out on the H file
you've got to try to keep things under
control but how do you do that he walked
right into this now the queen on C3 is
in line with the White Knight on F3 so
the G2 Pawn is frozen earlier the white
Pawn was one square back so there
wouldn't have been an attack on this
Knight and if that G2 Pawn is gone the
white king will also probably leave the
board with it that attack looks too
powerful so that was a I mean I don't
know if that got the two question marks
that normally blenders get but that was
a BL
from Wesley so and his time in this
tournament might be done look at him
look at his clock look at his position
this looks
terrible just turned around in the space
of one move as you say Robert just the
fact that the black queen now has access
to the third Rank and can sneak over to
get this white king the eval bar has
dropped through the floor White's going
for a Counterattack I'm not sure what
Wesley's trying to do here he's trying
to force the issue maybe trying to take
this Pawn off the board at some point
but surely just drag the white king out
from its hiding place there we go the
white forced forward and where's the
killer blow there are night checks in
the air Black's Rook can soon slide over
and uh it feels like at the right moment
the black Bishop's going to join in the
black Queen's going to join in the White
Knight is the only piece covering the
key squares but if you find the right
ingredients in the right order this is
simply going to be Checkmate um Alara he
is so strong at attacking surely he's
going to find something but only one
minute left and Wesley now needs to just
cross his fingers hope pre this white
king is surely living its last life now
um do we see it do we see the Checkmate
uh Tanya wow Rook h8 do you approve of
this one I like it it just gets The Rook
into the attack you're threatening to
blow open with the H Pawn moving forward
Knight F4 check now will be a big big
threat perhaps the idea is to go H1
Queen White takes it with the rook and
then Knight F4 check would have been the
killer blow so vesley needs to stop the
H Pawn he uses it as a shield comes back
now the bishop joins the attack and
alira all his pieces are playing but
this is getting crazy where is the
Checkmate coming in do you just we
go was Queen he gives up his Bishop then
his pass Pawn because the white king is
hunted resignation what a finish that
was sick from
Ala wow Wesley so is eliminated this is
it Ali Resa stays in the tournament he
wins a game that he was in so much
trouble but in the end what happened
there that attack Robert but I'm still
reeling in from it Wesley was in
driver's seat how did this even happen
well the tenacious defensive resources
of Ali Raza fuja you see his score in
Gold uh he feels like he just earned
himself some gold heftier payday by
moving on in the losers bracket as he
eliminates Wesley so the finalist in the
Champions chest T finals what a match
that was and not to be overlooked was
the match on the left hand side of our
screen one to one but they were trading
blows like two heavy weights going at it
I feel like we were just treated to some
spectacular
chests that was an insane insane round I
think we had two checkmates in both
these games and David I know there's so
much to show out of these games because
both were big tactical fights but you've
got to take us through where it all
turned around and the Beautiful Finish
that we just witnessed let's do it
lightning struck twice two checkmates to
decide those two games and with a Twist
this time let's check out those uh those
finales in the chess browser powered by
Opera and first of all let's start with
Yan Naomi with white against Maxi VRA
the black king now in huge huge trouble
white pieces lined up look at the
battery of the White Queen and Rook
especially on the H file instead though
Knight E7 check first to kick this black
king into the corner and now lining up
Bishop to G5 A P sacrifice allowing the
bishop to drop with check but the white
king slides to the opposite corner this
time safe and after Queen to G3 the
Beautiful Finish the check mating
pattern Queen takes H6 do your puzzle
Rush everyone because this is beautiful
if black had taken this Queen off the
board another check and now White's
three pieces and porn combin to trap the
black king a wonderful finish there from
yanomi and uh I think if possible we can
just switch over to the other game where
uh the other Checkmate was equally
beautiful from Ala fua but uh maybe
that's one to show later as uh first I
just wanted to mention if any of you
want to go and check out that Opera
browser yourself at home then uh it's
available on Windows Mac and Android and
it can be integrated directly into your
sidebar so for those of you like me who
love playing Blitz at home uh with the
boss not looking then uh Opera is for
you just make sure you going get fired
because chest can be super addictive
check out the Opera brow browser we've
got a big armagedon coming up to check
out who goes through in the bracket who
gets eliminated stay with us don't go
anywhere we'll be back with the
[Music]
bids
[Applause]
[Music]
BL
well hey everyone we're here at the
chess.com Champions chess tour finals
and of course Fair Play is a huge topic
for everyone around the world as it
should be including questions like can
you actually keep a venue secure can you
actually stop cheating even if it's some
of the most Advanced spyware level stuff
out there the answer is yes you can and
where I just entered is where the
players enter they can go directly to
their rooms and back from here but now
we're going to walk through as if we're
a regular person this guy's going to say
you don't belong here but okay Jokes
Aside all right now we're going to get
into the real stuff all right players
are brought down into this area before
games at a scheduled time so that they
have enough time to be fully checked for
fair play this right here is the private
Lounge area where only staff are allowed
to have Electronics the players are not
allowed to have any Electronics with
them once they've entered this area but
when they come early they do so because
they need plenty of time to get fully
checked by our fair play Tech I'll try
to talk a little softer cuz they're
actually playing their games right now
but okay at some point here a player
will come over and they'll wait in this
line before being asked to enter the
private fairplace screening area once
we're in this private fairplace
screening area the players wait only one
player in here at a time I'm standing
here right next to a sir who looks like
he has a fancy device what's your name
sir my name is my name is George I work
with the fair play Department my job is
to uh detect cheaters is to find out if
anyone is trying to get a gadget that
helps him win the game that's not going
to happen on my watch not going to
happen on his watch okay but all right
this is a little bit fancier than the
normal kind of thing you see an rfg
scanner what exactly is this is this
doing that's different it's called a
nonlinear Junction detector it's job is
to detect any signal signals transmitted
from another device outside or
transmitted from a device that is on a
player who's trying to cheat outside to
a uh foreign sender it can only be
acquired from specific countries it's
not like a normal metal detector that
you just buy on eBay it's a microphone I
guess I don't even know why we're doing
this I'm full of the things that are
going to get detected I didn't actually
hide anything here which is good to know
maybe I should have but okay we're going
to find out we'll see that's right don't
assume anything it's pretty phenomenal
stuff thank you George this is pretty
much just a bunch of cameras for the
show we do have cameras everywhere so
we're watching The Players no matter
what now after they've been scanned they
are not allowed to leave this area like
period during active gameplay so you're
talking about an area that is maybe more
secure than any over theboard chest
tournament that has ever been secured
that's what you're talking about right
and I hope that watching this video
showed you what we're doing I hope you
appreciate it it's some pretty high
level stuff I definitely am making a
call to every over theboard organizer to
invest in their own nonlinear Junction
detection devices cuz at this point if
you're not doing that you're not doing
it good enough and we hope that you will
consider investing in the same way that
chess.com has we
out
sh
and just before our break we saw an
explosive Checkmate from Al alera fua
against Wesley so and we just wanted to
break it down in uh slower time here the
big mistake by Wesley so opening up the
third rank for the black queen was
terminal but the punishment was
spectacular Pawn to H3 here from fuja
zeroing in on this white king in the
corner look how it was dragged out into
the open and then checkmated the White
Knight left forward to G5 but after a
capture Rook to h8 it looked like the
white king had found safety Refuge yet
again in the corner but no the bishop
jumped out to H3 look it looked like
white was suddenly getting chances a
Counterattack against the black king but
instead Bishop to G2 one of the moves of
the day so far just foring the white
king out into the open for a second time
not just that black makes a new Queen
sacrificing the beautiful pride and joy
of his position that pawn with the idea
that if Rook takes Queen Knight to F4 is
a check there's nowhere for the white
king to go no safe squares other than
the back rank but once you Retreat
suddenly Queen takes rook and this is
mate the white king now caught on its
back rank Spectacular from fuia a pawn
sacrifice a bishop sacrifice his whole
castle was burning there but he got the
enemy King this was spectacular and uh
remember if you want to check out Opera
yourselves then it also has cool
features built in like a VPN a browser
Ai and platforms like WhatsApp Tik Tok
are also integrated right into the
browser sidebar so fantastic play by
fuia and hopefully more of the same in
the upcoming
armed indeed DAV that's a big Armageddon
coming up Wesley so has been eliminated
and one of these two players will be
elim at and our bids are in Maxim V wins
the bid with 6 minutes 53 seconds Yi
bidding 7 minutes and 30 seconds Yan
will start with the white pie Maxim
starts with 6 minutes 53 seconds on the
clock starts with black but a draw means
that Maxim wins the match Yan has to win
with white David the players are ready
to go what do you make if the bids is
Yan does Yan's bid imply that he was
happy with the the white
pieces does seem to look that way it's
always hard to know in Armageddon it's
always about emotions who's Riding High
I mean I wouldn't be surprised if Yan
after that fantastic experience of
delivering Checkmate the queen sacrifice
that he just wants to get right back in
there more of the same a repeat but uh
he knows it's not going to be as easy
second time round and in Armageddon
there's that extra flavor of uh kind of
needing to win at all costs it adds a
bit of pressure um so y feeling
confident riding a high but um Max it's
up to him to do something different E4
will we see another night off Robert wow
apparently we have seen a night off an
aggressive opening and for Max Team I
think he's also happy to have the black
pieces after all yesterday he couldn't
get anything going against Dennis lazic
so now we have the start of a sicilian
where the players are playing for
different ideas we don't have a
symmetrical Pawn structure the Kings
have yet to Castle and curious moment
for Yan to pause Tanya I'm surprised
that he's spending time but the good
news is he has time to use use because
of his bid yeah absolutely and the two
decisive games that they had in the
rapid both were won by white the last
game played night off by Maxim Vash lra
did not go too well but it kind of was
like a hybrid with Maxim going with G6
Bishop G7 he's doing none of that like
you said this is a more strategic night
off the fight will be around the D5
square and as soon as I say strategic
the H Pawn is up the board throw that
strategy out of it out of the window
we've got fireworks already H4 coming in
what do we make of this WOW but he goes
with Development
David it feels a bit inconsistent from
Maxim Vash he said a he threw the black
H Pawn down the board but he didn't say
B he didn't kick this white knight away
maybe reluctant to drive the White
Knight forward into this F5 square and
uh watch out for him if he gets time
black to control the Knight by putting a
Pawn on G6 dominating this Steed on G3
it is a target um it's just about
whether npom nesi ends up having to
retreat this night or leaping forward if
he can jump forward successfully he will
do it he will love life but if he needs
to retreat not a good sign for white and
look at the clock situation Maxim's been
so Speedy smacks of opening preparation
Nomi on the other hand much much slower
and with the white king castle on this
flank it means we will not see a repeat
of that earlier game no big big attacks
against the black king which is yet to
declare its intent Robert definitely an
upgrade considering the previous game
for Vash gra well couldn't get any worse
that's for sure he was blown off the
board he was moving his Knights to their
starting squares but one of the big
questions about this position and in any
night nidorf is can black successfully
play the move D6 to D5 because that D6
Pawn it's a backwards Pawn that white
wants to barrel down on and if you could
play D5 the good news is you get rid of
that potential weakness you open up a
diagonal for your dark score Bishop in
particular but you also maybe leave some
vulnerable pawns behind namely the E5
Pawn which can become a Target so these
are the central questions and speaking
of central squares Knight to D5 giving
up a pawn temporarily wow what's the
followup here because loose pieces drop
off and yet Yan has not made his move
wow tactics already yeah David already I
was about to say that tactics on the
board uh and you said a pawn sacrifice
and he picks up the H five Pawn so a
temporary one but the computer the Valar
does not like it what's wrong with KN
takes spawn it looks like the most
natural move to me
simply that that pawn wasn't actually
too relevant in the position if anything
it's helped black a bit like that FIA
game with the Checkmate getting rid of
your pawns open up opens up lines for
your own attack look at this black Rook
now poised and uh the bishop also on
this diagonal the white king is not
feeling comfortable at all right now
it's also cost white two whole Tempe two
moves to go forward with the Knight and
then Retreat to take this pawn and uh if
you compared the quality just a few
moves ago of the white E Pawn versus the
black H Pawn no way should you trade a
Central Pawn for a flank Pawn like that
opening up your opponent's Rook so I
think just a step in the wrong direction
a misevaluation by aoni he's not dead
it's not over but wow Quin to C8 he's
lining up big threats this Arrow isn't
mine but white only good move according
to the computer at least Bishop takes G6
but look out if uh you don't take this
Pawn for black to strike on G2 the black
queen is actually lining up against this
H3 Square as well all hell is broken
loose it's chaos on the board
Robert help me through how should napom
even start trying to calculate this
position well I think that the reason
why Bishop takes G6 even works is it
looks like black is going to do the same
thing one of the big Ideas is a
sacrifice in front of the white king
with Bishop takes G2 but that white
Bishop it can slide back now that
there's no G6 Pawn anymore and in fact
white wins this game because the queen
is kicked off the diagonal and the H3
Pawn is defended so this is a big
tactical opportunity for Yan in fact we
see it on the board but look at what
Maxim has responded with Knight D4
Bishop takes G2 doesn't work but it
might work on the next turn that is the
threat the G6 Bishop is hanging and
while the engine can be critical of the
objective evaluation when all you need
is a draw if this could force the draw
you're happy to play in this style I
think that the white king is very
vulnerable Tanya I don't know if you're
with me here but how could you play this
way from the white side it looks too
dangerous this is terrifying for white
and I absolutely love Maxim's last move
jumping in with that Knight to D4 he
barely took any time to make that move
now the bishop on G6 is hanging because
the D5 Bishop doesn't hang anymore
you've taken control of the F5 Square so
as you pointed out Bishop takes G2 is a
massive threat right now not just that
also watch out if you were to play a
move like Bishop H5 trying to block out
the hline trying to fight the threat of
Bishop takes pawn bishop takes G2 the C2
Pawn will be hanging then the queen on
C8 the Knight on D4 all lined up
attacking the C2 Pawn you might fight on
the king side but your queen side's
falling apart Knight D4 is a star move
and Yana pishi is in big trouble David
totally agreed there's so many threats
he's trying to neutralize the threats
Now by trading pieces a good move good
classical wisdom from Yan pomi uh again
this Arrow indicating that black should
be trading pieces off and he does so uh
remember everyone at home if you're
being attacked trade pieces trade Queens
just try to survive the downside as
Tanya pointed out you're losing a pawn
now simply
this Pawn or C2 you were for a moment a
pawn ahead but that is a valuable Pawn
white is stuck with these three flank
pawns which are going to take an age to
ever March up the board but watch out
for black Central pawns to connect and
dominate the whole Midfield the whole
Center of uh the
board this is just oneway traffic
considering he just needs a draw this is
a dream for Vash gra he's not only
survived the opening uh Not only was he
asking the questions he's ahead on the
clock now and he's got the advantage on
the board why not push push forward for
Glory yeah and Robert I didn't even
realize the clock I mean this is crazy
Yana bom she's the one who had more time
to start with now he's behind on the
clock it looks like Maxim has managed to
pick up all the central pawns giving up
his FR flank pawns the D Pawn is moving
forward how do you see Yan fighting this
one how does he keep the game going and
that's what he needs to do I don't have
an answer specifically but generally he
needs to keep the game going and try to
get a mutual a Time scramble because
that's the way he comes back in this
position he needs to win he doesn't need
to equalize because let's say the way to
equalize is trading off the all the
pieces and shaking hands making a draw a
draw is a loss for the player with the
white pieces in Armageddon so how do you
stir up some trouble I don't think you
rush it a lot of people think when they
have to win they just go all in for an
attack they sacrifice pieces here you
just need to keep the game going somehow
because white has an outside pass Pawn
this H3 Pawn so in certain end games
that can be at the minimum of a decoy or
at the best it can become a passer and
hard to
stop for white right now but I love I've
got to say what Maxim is doing central
control uh these pawns control
everything they dominate the board and
uh he's also marched his King out into
the center we normally say don't try
this at home but with Queens off the
board you're unlikely to get checkmated
now knowing that a draw is sufficient
he's aiming to trade off the Rooks this
was shut down but uh watch out for these
pawns advancing I also love the fact
that the king is going to support the
Pawns
uh the horns are the pride and joy here
the foot soldiers but the king is going
to support them and uh just enforce the
advance inexorably towards the the
promotion squares and look at this
they're just going to steamroll
everything in their way the white
Bishops now lost two full Tempe the what
black king is going to come I'm itching
for this move the black F Pawn's going
to roll and uh I just don't see anything
for white to hope for here not just that
but he's reminding the white king that
on these lines look at this the two
black Rooks still poised just in case uh
you let your guard slip so right now
Vash gra It Feels Like Only the clock or
a blunder can trip him up four minutes
Robert you mentioned the time situation
lack of
increment it's going to become a race at
some point um do you think the positions
easy natural enough for bash gra to play
Under time dur us well a lot of his
moves have been easy to this point but
look what's happening and look at the
evaluation bar the king is in the center
Bishop H4 not an accurate response and
this White Knight that was sitting on G3
it could hop forward E4 maybe to C5 the
center might collapse at any moment so
Tanya as I look at this position and wow
he takes a step back which actually is
the better option I think that it's
Maxim who needs to prove that he can
stabilize here because his King is in
worse
shape yeah because it just felt like you
come back with the Knight you're
actually inviting Black's E Pawn to move
forward and Maxim doesn't make the move
I think he's calculating what happens
after white gives a couple of checks F5
comes to mind if you go forward with the
King to E5 perhaps Bishop F4 check is
the big threat watch out that D4 Pawn is
hanging with the Knight and the Rook on
D1 lined up so decision to be made in
the center by Maxim and it's not an easy
one he is going down on the clock once
again for Yan pishi there is a minute up
right now it's going to be a big
scramble it's going to be about who's
got the faster Mouse skills talking
about that what do we know about these
two players who's faster on the mouse
right now David I think they're equally
fast both AR super Speedy Vash when he's
on form he's so instinctive but he's
lost his rhythm he didn't keep things
simple and your idea now on the board
Tanya and the evaluation bar rising in
White's favor he over complicated it he
was trying to win King of the Hill
something we discussed yesterday but
this king's just walked into the lion's
den it's now a clear Target this Pawn
attacked three times due to the pin and
uh for black you're struggling to hold
everything together moves come to mind
like dropping the bishop back to F6 to
defend this Pawn but suddenly there are
other threats this check is going to hit
the black king again due to the pin
cannot be captured and white knight is
going to soon snack on this Central Pawn
multiple threats fash gravy's lost
control on both board and clock down to
two minutes he didn't keep things simple
he didn't trade off pieces he went for
the attack himself and uh he let things
slip and now okay attacking the Knight
but a check this Pawn surely is going to
drop off he's holding things together
with his King this is the braest king
I've seen in a long time well gets an
exclamation point it was the best move
and white is just a couple coordinating
moves away from winning that E4 Pawn as
you said not so easy and look at the
clocks I mean white is well ahead but
look at this last move the EV evaluation
bar it keeps going up and down this is
the clear best move and there there was
no other choice and as we look at the
scorecard beneath the board both players
have made a couple questionable
decisions but they also keep finding
these only moves when they must and for
a Maxim in particular that's important
because he is the one who has to defend
his King is in the open ananya people
like to think Queens are off the board
it's an end game this is a queenless
middle game a Checkmate could happen
especially against that black king well
Yi has been on the receiving end of a
checkmate with the king in the center
against Jose Martinez he might be the
one delivering it today as well and we
see that the Bishop from H4 H4 has been
pushed back but as long as the E4 and
the D3 Pawn remain alive for maxim that
gives Maxim a lot of chances so Yan
hasn't been successful in grabbing one
of these two pawns we're seeing
inaccuracies but you can't blame the
players for that there's no increment
it's high tension high pressure the
loser of this match gets eliminated out
of the cherel Masters anything can
happen but I'm loving those two pawns
it's Advantage Max teim right
now Al those are the strongest pawns
you'll ever see not just the bravest
King you'll ever see leading from the
front leading his Army to victory and uh
this looked a dangerous move for black
because this walks into a check a skewer
and this Pawn drops but after a check
the black king simply steps out the way
and actually we're going to see this
play out on the board the black Bishop's
ready to poach on this KN as well and
actually the more pieces disappear now
the quicker the kind of safer it becomes
as well and um yeah I think he's going
to at least bag the draw here at the
very minimum I was going to say take off
that Knight was this a mouse slip he's
trying to remove the bishop instead
given a question mark a bit of a
mysterious move that because now white
blocks and suddenly the black king is
under Fire again suddenly Pawn to B3 is
going to be a nasty check this one's
turning it's the time is the clock
situation that's going to decide this
game a minute up for Nomi and a pawn up
now on the board black pawns suddenly uh
unable to progress mistakes comeing
Pairs and sorry T I was just going to
say that several mistakes in a row from
Maxine V including this last move to
take this Knight on C3 it was David's
idea before but Tanya it's a bit too
late at this stage because what you
really wanted was to force Yan to take
it with the pawn I thought he was going
to grab it with the bishop but Yan
anyways takes it with the pawn now again
we saw the evalar not approve of that
the Knight is jumping and it's coming on
to C4 to start targeting that uh
blockade on D2 right now Rook takes Pawn
is the big threat which doesn't allow
Maxim to jump in just yet Maxim's got to
rush he's touching the one minute Mark
there is no increment this will come
down to
flagging this position is one where
there's a pass Pawn on D3 white is up a
pawn but black has the most impressive
one and you see the last couple moves
from black they are great decision
and another exclamation point given this
Rook can go up to C4 maybe over to a
it's just venturing forward and causing
problems white finally is pushing a pawn
but G4 now is loose in addition to the
Rook going to the queen side so with so
much pressure with so much on the line
for y palomi things are going wrong on
that fourth rank as black finally is
active black is active but white now
putting his King on the edge of the
board this is counterintuitive he's
trying to set a trap do not take this
Pawn with the black Rook because because
uh suddenly the white knight uh sorry
the white Rook would have eliminated the
Black Knight and white would have
trapped the opponent instead he's aiming
to remove the defender white Rook if
it's traded off can no longer prevent
the advance of this D Pawn it's going to
be a race but it looks like black is
simply ahead Black's Pawn too close to
touchdown the Knight is coming the king
is coming but a mistake Now by V gra
White's Pawn's R suddenly wh's ahead and
that's the point the King was needed to
stop those pawns and Maxim V he knows he
missed this idea Yan naushi is back in
the game all Maxim had to do was jump in
with the Knight to attack the bishop but
he's one move too late can white just
continue marching down the board with
the G Pawn ignore the bishop hanging on
D2 Robert you absolutely can as you see
those arrows that is what white should
do you can also first move the bishop
back to safety but look at the
evaluation bar to the left of the board
look at the trajectory of the game
beneath the board it was white being
worse then white being better then
suddenly White's completely winning
after black was winning the advantage
has exchanged hands unfortunately it's
not changing anymore white is winning
two pass pawns are better than
one and now Max K King David has to fall
back but it's too late and that's it
Maxim VRA resigns the gepon is
Unstoppable Maxim is eliminated y naishi
with a big Don around takes the match
wow David just unbelievable what we just
witnessed crazy stuff so many turns
around uh turnarounds we said it Maxine
played a great game he was so brave with
his King but ultimately the clock
situation punished him one slip and it
was all over and he is out of the chest
B
Masters Maxim V lra and Wesley Soul have
been eliminated Yan and alira fuja
continue their run what an Armageddon
that was an absolute roller Costa Robert
heartbreaking for maxim it's going to
hurt it's really going to sting and as
you see Yap pal she becomes the second
player who is already locked in to the
losers quarterfinal it probably should
have been Maxim Basher lra at least
that's how he feels but that was Steely
determination from Yan Naomi he never
Cav and he actually created
complications where it looked like they
didn't exist so Ali rais A fuja he
earned his match Victory after a slip
from Wesley so Yap pomi did much of the
same it looked like the other players we
going to get the job done but that's
what happens in these quicker time
controls in a Flash did the advantages
change hands so unpredictable this new
top time format this season on the
Champions chess tour we saw two of the
most beautiful checkmates you'll ever
see and ultimately it was those two
players who deliver the checkmates who
progress and will be gaining confidence
every single round they lived life on
the edge I'm going to say both players
really playing fast and loose there with
their pieces But ultimately rewarded for
their courage and commiserations to the
others who eliminated they'll be back
later this season wow just complete
turnarounds at the end in both those
matches Ali are surviving a big scare
against Wesley so it looked like Wesley
had the win in his hand and then that
turned around and here it looked like it
was going to be Maxim who makes it
through and then it turns around it has
been a shocking dramatic start here at
the chessable Masters but of course
that's not the only chance we've got
some great news uh for all of you
watching your regular College chess
League matches they're returning next
Saturday on February the 10th Mark the
date it's 10th of February tune in for
exciting team chess matchups between top
university level talents with commentary
from ccl's Jolie and the one and only
Anna crumbling will be back use the
command CCL in chat for everything you
need to
[Music]
know and of course we will be back for
more as the day is just started while it
has been the end of the road for maxim
Yi goes through the battle continues in
the winners bracket we will be back in
just a few don't go anywhere as Magnus
and Company will be playing more
[Music]
chess
take
[Music]
welcome everyone to the first ever
chess.com holiday party we're here with
the eight well seven of the Champions
chess tour finalist one of them is not
here but lucky for us as Santa I already
knew that one of the gifts might come in
in real handy so what we've got here is
a uh is a gift that keeps on giving for
some lucky lady out there right there
we're going to put Magnus right here in
between Max SE and Hikaru but let me
explain the rules real quick we have
eight numbers in here everyone here is
going to pick a number to decide the
order in which they go to choose the
presents in front the present can be
stolen if you like what someone else
gets you don't even have to pick a
present you can just steal their present
from them but once a present has been
stolen twice it is officially frozen you
can never steal that present again at
the end of the game whichever one of you
gets the number one gets to choose
whether to keep your present or make one
final steel to get the gift you want so
I'm going to go around
here I'm going to take the last number
lot like our fair play you know judge
jury and executioner over here right hey
there you go insert joke who's number
one okay SE B of the garage starts us
off let's do it well I guess this for my
guess look at that I know what you guys
thought you guys thought you were
showing up and every gift was going to
be a joke no it's not that's a Nintendo
switch place that every day I'm Number
Two okay I have the the best number the
worst number worst always that worse
than eight oh eight is the second best
oh really yeah cuz eight you get to have
all the information noice thank you I
got a box okay what's in the box I have
a smaller
box I got airpods wow oh sweeter every
white elephant has to have an ugly
Christmas sweater and you're the one who
got
it all right who's four
[Laughter]
okay you can cook theight that what
Denis here we go
okay is says
magnet
col show it to the camera the proud
owner all right hiar is shaking shaking
vag or is he
stealing who that
Danny that was not my idea all right I'm
going to have to use this one here
certificate of disposition and
Proclamation lord of the bong Cloud
opening okay I'm I'm a lord of the bong
Cloud here we go Wesley I'm going to
steal yeah yeah it's hard to choose I I
airpod go that's fair okay airpods have
been stolen it's official game on so we
have to keep the game going so I'm
taking your all
right okay he's rolling the dice he
loves an Nish that much okay Dennis
you've been set free oh you got the
switch okay Dennis lvic officially owes
the switch and thr tonight I guess I'm
taking he's taking the airpod airpods
are off the table which means Wesley you
have the power to choose a new gift oh
my gosh what is it are you
kidding yeah you're paying right yeah
that's the okay good I'll keep it okay
there we go that's it and that everyone
was our first ever white
elephant
n
he's down a be he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 they made a big mistake
oh and the bar's going up this is an
absolute Gem of a game Wesley s has done
it he going for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate second oh my God
what an armag get
in the 2021 World Blitz champion and the
2023 Champions chest to runner up Maxim
R lrav and Wesley so have both been
elimin ated of the Chess bable Masters
Yan pami alira fuja Advan through into
the losers quarterfinals and now it's
time for our big winner semi-finals
matchup we've got two underdogs fighting
each other the two big story lines
Dennis lazovic and josim Jose Martinez
with fantastic performances they will
play against each other one will go down
to the losers bracket and of course the
reigning tour Champion Magnus Carlson
will take on big fish F which match up
are you most excited about
David they're both juicy but I've got to
go for Magnus Carlson against fed it's
two of the best rapid players in the
world as evidenced by the world rapid
championship at the end of 2023 yes the
underdog fight is going to be
fascinating as well but I can't wait to
see how fed tries to work his way around
magnificent Magnus um it's going to be
one to watch it's really hard to pick
one out of these two uh Robert but I'm
going to put you on another spot here
Dennis laic taking on Jose Martinez now
Dennis in the last two days has taken
down Hikaru Nakamura Anish giri Maxim V
lra he is on some of the best chess that
he's ever played and Jos bam Jose
Martinez what a performance he had in
the plays then he takes on Yana pishi so
he's someone you can't write off Robert
is there a favorite in this one who do
you think will take it away we've got
two players on an absolute ter Jose
Martinez to her left hand side of her
screen he just celebrated his 25th
birthday by winning the play Then making
his way to division one where he beat
Yan the pomi a day ago and the right
hand side of her screen we have Dennis
the Menace Dennis lavic who took down as
you said hiar Nakamura Anish giri and
then yesterday Maxim vasher grv three of
the best players on the planet so I
started today with a reference to Alicia
Keys and her song Underdog go Google
that listen to that song I don't know
how to pick between these two and just
like Alicia Keys I'll root for them all
this is going to be an absolute great
clash between players with very
different styles Jose he likes to get
down to the waiting seconds he's a speed
demon with accuracy and I think that
Dennis has the superior openings between
these two he's a classically trained
player but he's only 17 so it's a bit
odd to see him play alongside some of
his
contemporaries yeah really interesting
The Clash of styles that they bring as
well as as you mentioned the Precision
of Jose Martinez in those seconds we've
seen him take those Dynamic decisions
and it will be fedos as well who'll have
to take some big decisions on his board
he will have to make the most of any
opportunity that presents himself
because he's up against Magnus Carlson
David break down this matchup for us
where do you see fedos should rely on
his
chances FV has to make it messy simply
uh both players the can do everything
both players love the end game they love
kind of outmaneuvering their opponents
as the material dwindles away but I do
feel fed's best chance is in that deep
dark Forest he needs to strike again
we've said it before while Magnus isn't
quite warmed up Magnus did beat Wesley
so yesterday but he wasn't quite at his
magnificent best it felt like he's just
still moving through the gears pedv has
has played a bit more chess in recent
days especially at this time format so
make things messy try to attack Magnus
if you can do not get buged out into a
long strategic fight it will not end
well uh in the meantime though Magnus
does start with white so first drob for
fed survive the first game then you can
think about maneuvering the opponent uh
when you have white in the
next it's a really good point starting
with the black Pieces Just make sure no
disaster strikes early and you alluded
to miky Tal's Forest of complication
where the path out is wide enough for
just one player so try to make the water
muddy try to get him into messy
situations Robert do you agree that that
is fed's best chance here try to get as
much chaos in well I think for fedos he
is a combed player by nature but it can
backfire and look at this he plays the
Petro defense from the black side which
I think is a good choice against Magnus
because Magnus Carlson is the better
player that's clear but what fedos where
he can backfire is just like against
Aliva fua in that fourth game he was
lost right he was down a couple pawns
but in the time scramble is where he was
able to shine so I think I think that
fedos he needs to keep the games going
Magnus is a brilliant speed chest player
he's won the speed Chess Championship he
made it to the finals of the bullet
Chess Championship but that's where he
has the most opportunity to go wrong
late stag of the game when you don't
have enough time so I think that fedos
he chose a wise opening in game
one times have changed when I was young
okay Magnus there a bit distracted maybe
closing the curtains but when I was
young this opening if anyone played uh
This Way against the Petro trying to
trade off Queen early we would have
laughed them out of Chess we would have
told them this isn't the game for you
you know you're too timid nobody likes
players who play for a draw but Magnus
plays this type of position for a win
it's so symmetrical but white has two
extra temp for now and it's all about
placing the pieces on their best squares
yes the Queens have gone I I guess
Magnus is simply arguing that there's
enough forces there's enough of his army
left to cause some problems later he's
beaten the likes of yand pomi before in
this type of position but
I'm still skeptical uh Magnus why why
not entertain us we want to see more
checkmates but fed have he's going to
emerge unscathed from the opening and uh
the battle's really going to be
postponed towards the end game now uh
Robert surprised at all U are you Es
scaving as me maybe I'm being a bit too
harsh about this opening choice I was
surprised but I think there's fos of
playing something that he doesn't always
Trot out so I think that Magnus Carlson
as you said he likes getting positions
where there isn't so much risk he can
outplay his opponent and we saw just
before the latest move that the draw
rate was through the roof so Tanya when
the history shows that black can hold on
quite frequently I think players they
think let's go for that but against
Magnus Carlson it's a totally different
game absolutely agree with you this is a
queenless middle game while there is a
an obvious bit a big threat on the board
immediately by Magnus that Knight
jumping in Knight takes C7 so it's
something that you need to take care of
immediately he falls back with the
bishop and yes uh the Queens are off the
board but the gloves are still on
because I think the players want to
still fight it out Magnus we've seen him
do crazy things in the end game so I'm
still expecting this to be a fight he's
fighting for more space right now uh
it's going to be a battle it's going to
be a slow one but we've got a game on
our hands it's far from over when you're
playing against Magnus I think it only
gets scarier when the Queens are
off I'm inclined to agree I've suffered
so many times at the hands of Magnus I
think we all have it Point uh once the
Queens are off he knows better than
anyone he just has this feel of where
the pieces belong uh he spins his web
and uh sooner or later it does get
tactical it does sharpen up and then he
takes his
chances I've got to say he's handled
this really well no weaknesses at all in
the black Camp Black's King is castled
The Rook will slide across to E8 it's
just about how white develops the pieces
the white king needs to choose a side
maybe it'll sit in the center but I
don't see why black should ever be worse
you kick back the White Knight you
develop your own pieces uh this should
be level with equal play it's just about
whether Magnus can uh exert that magic a
bit later um without meaning to be too
pessimistic about this game should we
check out the opening the early stages
of the other battle The Clash of The
Underdogs Jose Martinez against Dennis
lazic that one still early doors as well
but uh okay looks like a quiet variation
of the Spanish um very symmetrical there
as well Robert uh what do you make of
that opening who's it going to favor on
the left hand side of our screen we see
a position with no pawns have left the
board only a pair of knights for each
side so it's a slow start for both of
these games uh both uh matches I think
they're just settling in without
creating any major threats and Dennis
lavic uh he has the black piece in this
game he is incredibly difficult to
defeat not only yesterday when he
outlasted Maxim vasher lrav in
Armageddon by having a position that was
never worse from the black side but I
remember in the 2023 season he played a
match against Sam Sean who's about super
Grand Master one of the best players in
the United States and they drew 12 games
in a row all right he just doesn't lose
no matter who he's playing so it's a a
rare sight for him to actually get in
trouble because he's so solid and it's
no surprise to me in this game Tanya
that Jose he is thinking trying to come
up with some ideas that give him
advantage and D is saying no you're not
going to get that because I am one of
the most grounded players in the
planet yes I think it's so important for
Jose to try to just keep as many pieces
on the board try and get Dennis low on
the clock but Dennis so far has been
doing great he's got about a minute and
a half Advantage there I think the one
spot where perhaps Jose would have a
better chances if it becomes a true time
scrumble we've seen Jose do amazing
things which is seconds on the clock
meanwhile in the previous season we saw
Dennis go down on the clock and struggle
in those situations especially if the
position was still complicated tennis
has great endgame technique Jose
meanwhile he seems to really Thrive when
there are complications and less time on
the clock so this is going to go down to
those seconds who's got those extra
seconds when there's a Time scramble
it's still far off from now a really
level start right now I'm already
looking at ideas for jospin can he try
and go all out can he try and strike in
the center there are two breaks that
come to my mind Robert D4 or F4 is this
something that black needs to keep an
eye out on for sure and I just want to
point out you called him josam and some
like who's josam I don't see any josams
here Jose is a streamer he's a content
creator and that is his online handle so
uh well I I agree with you David I'm
going to throw it to you because I'm not
sure what white should aim for is it
going to be D4 is it going to be F4 how
are you opening up this position R
D5 I think the answer is neither after
Dennis lack's last move uh Tanya your
ideas scared Dennis so much that he
decided to strike first and why not if
you are able to set up a strong Pawn
Center like this with either color
normally you're the one holding the key
to the center uh you're the one who
decides when to trade off later um it's
up to Dennis when to take this Pawn in
the center but first of all okay a trade
there White's Knight was too strong on
F5 could not be tolerated and now white
has the bishop pair so uh I'm liking
Black's Pawn Center but I'm liking the
potential of these white Bishops
especially if white gets one or two more
moves is able to Unleash the Beast and
uh this bishop and Queen on the same
diagonal check mating threats in the air
not right now but Dennis has to watch
out for that uh first I'm expecting him
to just continue in his trademark style
Dennis lavic improve his pieces bring
all the pieces to the party nice
coordination and that's why he very
rarely loses games he doesn't leave any
structural weaknesses ever I very rarely
see him with doubled pawns for example
and he nearly never has bad pieces
either so yes white has the longer term
advantage of the Bishops but uh I think
he's doing
every um Roberts how should Jose start
playing now what would give white reason
for
optimism well I I'm not entirely sure
and I don't think Jose knows what to do
either he is below on the clock and as
you were pointing out when you have
Bishops you want open space open
diagonals but any pawn move or capture
it leaves either a square or potential
weakness behind and we did just see that
exchange of Pawns in the center black
can take back pretty much with any of
the three pieces that can take on D5 but
it's also this bishop on C7 who that may
get an open diagonal in the future if
black continues to push in the center so
I love this from Dennis Tanya he takes
with the pawn on D5 that would been my
first instinct do you like the Pawns in
the center or the fact that white can
challenge them I like the Pawns in the
center I think they control not only the
squares like C4 and E4 but also give
black more space once the E Pawn might
move forward in a certain time the
bishop and C7 will open up the D Pawn
might move forward at the right time
opening up the defile it's just more
flexibility look at that the queen and
the bishop are already lining up there
are threats along the diagonal E4 is
something that white always has to watch
out for I think C takes D5 is uh is a
choice that a lot of us would also make
intuitively in this position what do you
think David is that uh is that a
recapture that would have been your
choice as well definitely I think these
top players the reason they're so good
and the reason they're able to get so
many wins in Rapid is because they're
always looking for the most ambitious
move and um Dennis he had to play some
solid uh choices earlier he had to give
up his lights s Bishop for a night but
now he's playing ambitious chess he's
lined up his Rooks look at those pieces
he's lined up the queen and Bishop yes
they're not going anywhere now but more
importantly he's got the Pawns in the
center what to do next is anyone's guess
who knows it's become very uh strategic
very KY it's about when uh one of the
sides decides to push in the center Pawn
D4 for black pawn to D4 for white is
going to be the key as well but um I
like the way that Dennis has handled
this so far I think he needs to keep
pieces on Bishops gaining power
especially the bishop pair together the
kind of deeper you get into a game the
more the board clears up but uh for now
everything under control and uh yeah
Robert I think the clock situation as
well we mentioned it Dennis he's doing
everything right he's keeping his time
Advantage essential long term in this uh
match as a strategy and he's keeping the
tension alive I think he can continue to
opt for improving moves I would
potentially double Rooks on the E file
waiting before I decide to push a pawn
and create new tension so Dennis he has
several options Queen C6 also looks very
smart because it opens up new avenues
maybe Pawn to D4 for black the bishop on
C2 is a loose piece and the white king
may not feel fully safe if that diagonal
open so both sides are trying to figure
out which diagonals they can operate on
it's not entirely clear although I think
what is clear is if you give white one
free move it's going to be a skewer and
a win of a rook for Bishop so I mean
this is a great play very precise play
from both both these players and Tanya I
think in both of our boards we just are
seeing quiet little moves improving
decisions but very sturdy from all four
of these winner
semi-finalists yes and I really like
that Dennis has buried that threat with
an active move Rook to E6 also
controlling the sixth rank we might see
The Rook Shuffle on to the king side
also takes control of this A6 Square
stopping that white Pawn from moving
forward on the left side of our screen
just a simple Harmony in Black's
position on Dennis's board I like the
way he's placed the pieces and there is
this incredible maturity in his play
that I've seen I've seen it in the tour
season last year I've seen it in the
cherel Masters so far this year the
queen has attacked Denis needs to find a
good Square for that Queen he moves it
back onto the diagonal into the center
of the board his strategy his positional
understanding where the pieces belong it
all seems to fall into place so well and
it's just not on the board I was so
impressed with his answers yesterday
when we when you asked him David who's
your idol who's your hero the guy just
said I've got no Heroes he's 17 and it's
just amazing to hear him talk and to his
play is a true reflection of his
personality I think toally in order to
be the best you have to beat the best so
you can't be too differential towards
them you have to respect them but not
worship them too much you have to be
ready to pounce when the best players in
the world make mistakes and talking of
the best players in the world we see
Magnus Carson against fed uh that one as
well evolving there have been some big
decisions uh in that Clash the world
number one has castled queenside with
the white king the board you see on the
right of your screens there uh he's also
got the bishop pair so both players with
the white pieces in these two boards
have the bishop pair long term doing
very well but still KGI for now and fed
of trying to maneuver around with his
Knights um white Pawn structure in that
game Magnus Carson against fed slightly
compromised white has doubled awns so
many small factors to break down and
it's not clear who it favors yet
evaluation bar on both boards slightly
favoring white but not by much and uh it
feels like again Calm before the storm
this middle game and the clock ticking
that could be a key factor especially
the Magnus Carson game he's just gone
below the four-minute Mark we mentioned
sometimes in the time scrambles even
mighty Magnus makes mistakes so um I
think we've de deeper into that game uh
let's jump in Magnus Carson against fed
to try to evaluate has he worked this
end game magic we've been talking about
this queenless middle game we'll call it
and uh here I've got to say first glance
I like white purely because of this
Knight that he's just installed on the
C6 square but uh black has reasons to be
optimistic too Robert yeah this is a
position where it resembles the other
game in that white has the pair of
Bishops but the Queens are off the board
and of note is this doubled a pawns for
white but that's not actually a bad
thing at this stage of the game with so
many pieces remaining on the board and
white can go after some of Black's
targets and black is not creating a pass
Pawn because the A2 Pawn still covers
the pawn on the B file this is maybe a
deep concept for some but the point is
that it's not like some other double
pawns as we saw in yand pomi versus Maxi
Vash earlier so this last move from from
fedos excuse me great decision he's
trying to bring a knight to E5 or to C5
and that A4 Pawn is a target a knight in
the center usually is a good place to
put it and he wants to activate his
pieces including the bishop on d8 which
does have a new diagonal to work with
without the knight in its path so Tanya
as we look at this position I think all
of us were inclined to believe that
white is better but I feel like there's
some natural plans for
black agreed and uh the point that you
just made with Bishop on d8 stepping up
to F6 taking control of the wrong long
wrong the long diagonal A1 to h8 Once
White's Bishop comes to D4 it looks like
magnus's Bishop Bishop pair Advantage is
going to be neutralized really soon
either there'll be a knight trade from
C5 or the bishop trade from F6 and the
Pawn's structural weaknesses in magnus's
Camp more than enough compensate for
fedos the lack of the bishop uh I love
that night on C6 but I'm trying to
understand why is our evalar favoring
white so much Bishop D4 there seems to
be Bishop F6 if not the Knight is
jumping forward into the game what's
going on here whoa that's going on here
that's what's going on
here we didn't expect that and uh again
the blue arrow indicating that Black's
only move or at least by far the best
move is Rook takes Bishop that would not
have been on my radar Robert an exchange
sacrifice pretty much demanded uh by fed
right now this is a pawn sacrifice and I
just wanted to point out let's jump in
if this Pawn is captured if you just
whip this Pawn off the board what could
be more natural go up material suddenly
a new diagonal for White's uncontested
light squar bishop and trick tactics in
the air black has two loose pieces on
this diagonal and something might well
just drop off so don't be too greedy I
think likewise if uh you capture this
Pawn with the Knight there are problems
tactically Bishop takes and suddenly
watch out for your back rank you can
trade off a set of Rooks but uh now you
have to be careful if Pawn takes
suddenly a deadly check and your Bishop
will simply drop off next move so Magnus
initiating the tactics let's just show
what he okay he's played Pawn takes Pawn
he needed to play Rook takes Bishop and
uh basically admit that uh okay if Rook
takes there are tricks in Black's favor
this time with a nice pin but Pawn takes
Pawn Robert do you think this is going
to backfire fed say of playing that move
instantly and look at magnus's reply
what you were calling for David Bishop
to B5 there are too many tactics now and
so what Magnus did is he gave away a
pawn to free up diagonals for his
Bishops and I say Bishops plural because
now that Knight on D7 if it continues to
move say to E5 well oh and he does it
move too late to F say of the right idea
wrong move order I still feel like he
has chances to survive this game let's
not count him out just because the
evaluation bar is slightly in mag's
favor the material imbalance now is
Knight and one Pawn for rook and let's
not forget about those opposite colored
Bishops so black can use the dark
squares to his Advantage white is going
to try to operate on the light squares
but to what end what light squares are
actually valuable that's an essential
question so I like the way that fedos is
handling this I think this gives him the
best practical
chances
far from out of it it's uh just
imbalanced as we would say Tanya the
players have no idea who's better and uh
fed sa I could see him especially if he
gets this pawn two squares further down
the board him working things in his
favor do you think Magnus needs to be
careful as well I'm materialistic I love
the fact that there is an extra exchange
for white and I agree that Black's got
compensation but that Knight on C6 the
bishop on B5 there are these tactical
ideas of either Knight takes A5 or
Knight takes B4 next watch out the
Knight on D7 is still hanging it's a
threat that you need to take care of to
me it just feels that FV needs to be on
the defense he needs to keep the
activity going he has to play active to
defend this position the plan that
you're pointing out of the C Pawn moving
forward the bishop on B5 right now takes
control of that so it still requires a
bit of prep right now I'm expecting fedf
to move his Knight he does it KN to B6
the evalar hits it and Magnus just
continues to keep opening up the
position the lines for the Bishops and
the the lines for the Rooks and the
diagonals for the Bishops and now it's
busted for black this is a problem once
this Rook gets in the game you can see
that fedos is in trouble I think it's
important to analyze what he could have
done instead and it was just a one move
play from fedos that would have kept him
in the game rather than opening the
Rooks up Bishop to G3 just trying to
blockade this dwn so the Rooks don't
have open files when you're down
material especially when your opponent
has two Rooks just just one for yourself
you need to keep those Rooks contained
so this would have been a good choice
instead what we see in the game the
Rooks are loose they are free to run
about the board and now one of them is
off the board and that's bad news for
black because that A5 Pawn is tender the
defile remains open black can't keep
everything under his control and Magnus
Carlson for sure is winning this first
game
David 100% it's all about that Target on
A5 pretty much indefensible in the uh
kind of short term and uh this white a
pawn not only does it promote on a light
Square Guided by your Bishop but it's
pretty much Unstoppable you have no
Rooks left as black yeah Knights are
terrible at stopping these Corner pawns
these Rook pawns so once the White
Knight Retreats takes this Pawn it's a
matter of time before fed has to resign
we saw him sit back exhale a moment ago
he knows it's over the white Rook
doesn't look impressive now but it will
soon join the fun and uh I think we see
very simple plan Black's counter blate
far too slow and uh Magnus he's going
porn hunting he's is going to hunt down
the full point in this game uh soon
closing out the victory again just in
the space of one or two moves this is
how strong the top players are they
punish you one small imperceptible slip
and here we go Knight takes porn
inevitable just a straightforward plan
Magnus about to bank it um we think
Tanya should we go to the other game
where there's still action on the
board definitely I just want to say this
is how strong Magnus Carlson can be
especially in these positions I mean we
were talking about an equal opening an
outcome where White had nothing and then
just out of nowhere Magnus comes up with
a winning position how did it happen
when did it all go so wrong it's just
unbelievable how he makes these things
just appear on the board and makes chess
look so easy it's insane he's playing
against one of the best players in the
world he has a completely winning
position out of a completely equal
opening Magnus Carlson just doing Magnus
things I think it's a good time David to
jump over to our other board Which is
far from a queenless position it's an
exciting middle game Robert what do you
make of what we're seeing on the left
side of our screen between Dennis Lac
and Jose Martinez it's definitely
heating up on the left hand side board
because they're open diagonals for both
players usually open space it is good
for the player with the pair of Bishops
as Jose Martinez he has cameras in the
bottom left hand side of our screen but
Dennis lvic he just doesn't back down
against anyone it's super impressive
that the game between Magnus and federos
is officially over no surprises there
Magnus takes game one so now we can
fully be attentive to this game on the
left hand side of our screen between
Jose and Dennis Magnus up one to nothing
one of these players would like to join
him I mean David look at Jose's clock
he's down under that minute but we know
he's a bullet brawler he's won a number
of
them we we used to seeing this from Jose
at this point yesterday against Yan pomi
every time we jumped into that game he
had like five 10 seconds on his clock
yet he was able to maneuver he
checkmated yand pomi twice and wow is
this a blunder from Dennis lazic why is
this a mistake Queen to F6 he's trying
to trade off the Queens but Rook takes
D5 just wins a piece there's actually
wow some brilliant tactics here some
back rank
ideas I wonder whether he'll see it if
not we will show it a double question
mark a blunder but an understandable one
from Dennis lazic and J bam Jose
Martinez spots it Queen sacrifice double
exclamation mark and he's going to show
the reason look at this Rook takes D4 at
the end a pin and you win you're going
to emerge with a rook and two Bishops
for a queen mathematically this one is
pretty much over brilliant Robert just
in the blink of an eye and you could see
Jose he was quizzically looking at wait
this doesn't look right I didn't spot
Queen F6 on my radar and Dennis shakes
his head like I should have seen that
come on and the point is that lose
pieces drop off a rook and two Bishops
they overwhelm a queen it's worth more
in value Bishops two Bishops and a rook
that's worth 11 maybe even 12 to a
queen's nine so this one it should be
easy conversion now Tanya I mean Dennis
Laz he doesn't blunder often but he just
had a critical error at that moment and
now it seems game one for Jos Rob we've
been talking about how Dennis makes no
mistakes it we haven't seen that happen
and this was a big tactical blunder and
this puts him on the back foot I think
it's a hard one to recover from the
bishop can line up now in Bishop to E4 a
huge pin you have to watch out for there
will be coordination between the rook
and the two Bishops one of the Rooks
will come on to the open file either the
Bel line or the airline and for Dennis
lavic it is a desperate situation too
much material down you have to be a
little careful white needs to fall back
with the bishop the D3 Pawn can be
picked up at the moment because the Rook
on E2 is tied down to defend the bishop
on D2 yes that pawn may drop but David I
feel like this is for someone of Jose's
caliber just so easy this is a cakewalk
for him because you're going have to
push your pawns that opens up more
diagonals and the white king is too
safe simply black has fewer pieces
you've got a queen great but uh Rooks
and Bishops do a great job at containing
a queen and you have two of those
Bishops so yeah it feels like a matter
of time Jose he's done the hard work but
then again there are tricks uh I was
goingon to say is there a trick he was
wow double attack suddenly from Dennis
lazic
BL yeah he thought Queen D1 check he
missed Queen B5 Tanya what a f from
Dennis and Jose can't believe it and it
was because he was down to 5 seconds on
the clock he's in big danger now and
maybe white is still fine because you've
got that extra pawn and you can set up a
fortress but this is heartbreaking Jose
needs to get himself together and make
sure that there are no more misses right
now he's down to seconds on the clock I
think he's still going to win the game
David I don't know about you but I'd
much rather have all of these pieces for
the queen there's no attack against
against the white king but Jose he still
shaking his head David I don't think
he's over
it understandably he's going to be
kicking himself he had an easily winning
position we were just praising him uh
talking about how it should be pretty
much automatic and it would have been if
he hadn't walked into a double attack so
moral of the story everyone keep your
pieces defended protect each other
coordinate loose pieces drop off and he
put his Bishop on A5 far away from the
rest of his army no surprise that the
tactics didn't work in his favor but
okay he's going for the black king now
Bishop H5 a monster threat Dennis has to
work out with no time on his clock can
he simply take this Pawn I think he can
but then he might have to run with the
black king forward so uh still scary
times here Jose recovering but setting
the traps Bishop H five still on top
Dennis this is not over he still has to
find really accurate moves to save
this David that's a really nice move
taking away that F6 s Bishop H5 Rook to
E8 was a big threat check's coming in I
I think this is is going to end in a
draw now that the queen and the King are
separated you're not going to lose the
queen but without white having connected
pawns it's hard to imagine a passer for
Jose
either the most likely uh oh what a find
he gives away his Pawn to save his King
and now a draw I would say is more
likely but Tanya until that move was
found I thought that Dennis was in some
trouble W and Jose continues to Shak is
that he can't believe what he's just
missed he was rook and two Bishops for a
queen blundering in one move but this is
this is rapid chess and he shakes his
head he knows this is over this is
ending in a draw any moment now David
miracles do happen Dennis lazic that's
why you never ever give up he blundered
he was pretty much just a piece down for
nothing but he kept fighting and even
there they were checkmating attacks
against his King but he's a coldblooded
Defender so impressive stuff um yeah
just tactical vision for both of these
two players really at the top of their
game you can tell two slips one on
either side ultimately balancing each
other out and now we will see a
repetition and draw is confirmed Battle
of the underdogs in the end after a few
twists and turns after a roller coaster
ending peacefully wow breathless action
Tanya that was an up and down game what
a game that was a big blunder by Dennis
first and then Jose Martinez Returns the
favors with just seconds on the clock
and you can see the one player who is
disappointed with this result for Jos
bam it has been a disappointing draw
Robert he was so close oh he was so
close to securing game one against
Dennis lazic but Dennis he has a lot of
fight in him he may just be 17 but he's
used to brawling here on the internet in
the chess scene and you see that Dennis
he has reason to smile he now is tied
half half after a single game meanwhile
Magnus Carlson he won his first game so
I don't think Vladimir FV is feeling
happy in the slightest
for FV he needs to make a comeback in
his match he needs to score a win to
level the score Magnus doing Magnus
things in that one out of nowhere out of
a quick Queen trade he just makes one of
the most difficult games known to
mankind chest makes makes it look also
easy just converts it in a couple of
moves I don't know how the guy does it
David what is the
secret you know maybe it's something in
the water in Norway either ways he works
miracles and we saw the mess the madness
uh the kind of loss of control in that
last game between Martinez and lavic
Magnus having none of it just seamless
asking questions of his opponent and
unfortunately for fed who we see on the
camera right now he didn't quite have
the answers uh he looks very
philosophical I've got to say staring
out to the distance just wondering where
it all went wrong maybe he's just coming
up with a new strategy but that is what
we were talking about you cannot let
Magnus assume control assume dominance
in one of those slower strategic type of
positions he out Maneuvers the best of
us you need to take your chances ask
really difficult questions make the
position irrational and just hope that
it pays off unfortunately that's the
best chance against one of the best
players of uh Jess and I think we're
getting ready to go any moment now
Magnus doesn't look too happy but he
played great in that first
one Robert I'm still thinking about what
we spoke earlier for fed he needs to
find a way to get those positions where
2 plus two is indeed equal to five to
find his
chances def Forest though is hard to
find and to navigate against Magnus
Carlson because he's the number one
player in the world he's been that for
over a decade so if anyone has the
compass even when it seems like they're
blindfolded and on their own it's Magnus
so I feel like for fedos of he showed
yesterday that he can storm back from a
deficit but what he did against Ali Raza
fuia is he went all out he he put his
Queen off the side of the board stole a
pawn was greedy I'm not sure it's going
to work two days in a row so fedos he
starts with a pretty quiet opening we'll
see if he's willing to throw his pawns
forward just like we saw for example
Anish giri do at the end of Tata of
Steel sometimes you have to throw all
your pieces forward everything but the
kitchen sink and go for the attack
David yeah I fully agree and uh he would
love to do that I've seen fet have do
that plenty of times with a lot of
success but against different type of
opposition of course is easy to say
against someone that he would outrate
throw your pawns forward attack go for
it and it's another whole mind set to do
it against Magnus so uh right now it's a
Queen's Gambit declined it's the K's bad
Pawn structure we've been talking about
with pawns on E3 D4 against pawns on C6
D5 but Magnus loves these types of Pawn
structures now he's aiming to trade off
these Bishops and the fewer pieces on
the board the uh better Magnus becomes
remember so I love this decision I was
about to say keep those bits on keep
those Bishops just in case you need them
for a later attack Magnus doesn't look
too happy what do you make of the body
language and the start of this game
Tanya the way he won the first game I
think he's got all the reasons to be
happy right now it's hard to say how
he's feeling but I think he's very
pleased with the quality of player from
that game one he jumps in with the
Knight to the center of the board uh and
for white I was just about to say needs
to take a decision fedf does he put the
Knight on F3 or the other plan that we
see with the Knight moving in front of
the king to E2 instead fed she chooses
the approach where eventually the Knight
can jump further on the Knight can land
on to E5 we might even see him try to
build Chances with shock Castle the F
Pawn moving forward F4 F5 in certain
positions but having white he needs to
make sure that he does create as much of
a possibility to get a game out of this
one as much as he can because it only
gets harder harder on from him well with
the white pieces he has two whites in
these final three games does fedos say
have as you're saying Tanya he needs to
make the most of it and I like his
position optically it's pleasing you
have all four of your minor pieces out
on the third rank you control ke squares
and namely the F5 square like black
can't easily jump forward in this
position and so the next moves aren't
obvious for how black should develop
your Bishop on C8 it's tucked at home
you may want to go all the way out to G4
but that walks into Tanya's plan with
Knight to E5 so David as we look at this
position you know Magnus very well he
might have to settle for a cramped
structure do you think that he's quite
displeased with what he's achieved out
of the opening I think Magnus is happy
with the pawn structure he's got the
he's happy with the skeleton of the
position but uh as you say Robert
there's no natural plans and uh Magnus
is's probably better than anyone at just
putting his pieces on good squares
finding nice homes for them here It's
Tricky even uh for the likes of Magnus
and like you say awward squares so he's
in two minds he's happy that he's got a
solid foundation but awkward squares for
his pieces like this E6 Point uh we
never like to see Bishops uh kind of
staring at their own pawns they look
like big Pawns in this type of position
and yeah it's just about how Magnus uh
is able to maneuver maybe after pushing
the a pawn he'll bring his Knight out
via A6 maybe he'll bring the Knight back
round to sit by his King he's Rock Solid
and he's a point up in the match so he
has something to play with it's just
about whether fed can attack uh on the
flip side I don't really see exactly
what white should be doing often here we
talk about minority attacks throwing two
pawns forward to uh undermine these
three on the queen side but that is less
attractive with the Black Knight sitting
in the center nicely poised to jump into
any holes uh later on and there we go
fed save he's maneuvering this is
exciting this is instructive as well
going towards this black king he's just
edging uh towards the king side he's
going to try and put some pressure on
this black Bishop first of all but watch
out for some nasty checks just in case
if you keep uh kind of if you forget to
keep your king uh safe later so yeah I
could go on about these Pawn structures
forever I'll stop now but I think that
Magnus isn't as comfortable as he would
like to be
T I agree with and I think for Magnus
it's also going to be key to try and get
a central break of C5 in at the right
moment because if fight is given a free
hand we can see that attack Brewing up
on the king side Knight F4 Knight E5 you
might eventually jump with the Knight to
H5 the F F Pawn moving forward so if for
Magnus once he's already lined up the
queen with the bishop also hinting at C5
Knight can come to D7 or A6 and defend
that I was expecting fedf to land on the
E5 square with his Knight but we see a
different plan here Bishop to E5 Robert
does this surprise you it does and I
think that Magnus suddenly has fixed all
of his problems because his latest move
bring his Queen to C8 may look unusual
but he's lining his Queen and Bishop up
so Bishop to F5 trade pieces when you
have less space and in this position
black is feeling a bit cramped you
haven't fully developed SO trading
pieces should be favorable for Magnus
Carlson and as soon as I say it he plays
it I think that he has neutralized the
opening Advantage from the white side
but the game continues because there
isn't complete clarity as David pointed
out White's Knights are heading towards
the black king it can be a bit scary if
you are not accurate but now that the
development is complete I do think
Magnus he has everything under control
and it's a timely uh sip of water or
whatever is in that bottle there because
he's feeling good about his position in
t yeah I think David you were asking
about magnus's body language I think
this has got to be a lot more relaxed
for him now now that one set of minor
pieces are off the board he's managed to
get rid of well what is considered one
of the big problem pieces in these kind
of Pawn structure the light Squad Bishop
you really want to trade that off and
he's done it which solves a lot of
problems but still white feels like
setting up for that Minority attack you
had mentioned earlier The Rook now lined
up with the queen B4 A4 B5 in the air uh
how does black continue to improve and
fight these ideas
David well uh Magnus knows better than
me but uh he has a few options uh I just
wanted to say completely on your point
Tanya the pawns control light squares
now the bishop will control dark squares
later so great strategy uh and also a
note for everyone at home if you're
cramped if you're struggling for space
if your pieces are suffocating just
trade off one set of minor pieces
Knights and Bishops and you live uh you
kind of breathe easier and uh yeah I was
going to say actually on the last move
Magnus could have gone for a double
attack I was slightly surprised the
Black Knight didn't jump in to hit this
Porn first of all uh which has just
moved it was sitting on B2 but also the
black knight from C4 would have hit this
bishop in the center um so Magnus could
have actually forced the issue traded
more pieces off and felt probably safer
uh but now what he would love to do is
somehow get either the Queens off or
maybe one set of knights off he'd love
to trade off white Bishop sitting pretty
in the center um ultimately though there
we go I was going to say just before
that magnus's trademark move is to push
Rooks pawns flank pawns um reinvigorated
by Alpha zero in 2019 Magnus had one of
his best years and he loves kind of
gaining space on the flanks watch out
now for this backward Pawn to be an
issue later than black Rook could slide
AC so Magnus has got a bunch of ideas in
the meantime I don't really see what fed
should be doing right now uh ultimately
this Pawn structure is something Magnus
is known for and fed I thought he
opening was a success but one or two
moves later the departure of those
Bishops and suddenly it's just a
position as we say it's just roughly
level and uh I do fear if his chances um
so okay this is one to check in on a bit
later um maybe let's zoom out and go to
the bird's eye view to check in on the
other game The Clash of The Underdogs
after those Mutual blunders a bit
earlier who will recover best and uh
Robert we see it on the left s left hand
side there first glance who do you favor
oh we got that bony structure on the
left hand side of our screen and Jose
Martinez just hops in with his KN I have
to say that his position looks very
solid from the black side Dennis lazic
you know not like he's done anything
wrong himself he's pushing pawns into
Center but I think that there are
chances for black to strike and that is
the standard
for this opening so as we dive in to the
X's and O's I just also want to note
that the clock the situation seems
perfectly acceptable for both players
but I'm looking at strikes over on the
queen side for black with a move like
Pawn to B5 that's one of Jose's main
ideas and for Dennis he's expanded his
Center can he push F4 next to boot that
Queen out of there Tanya these are not
easy decisions but you're a D4 player so
you must have experience in the
structure you're right Robert and in
these positions it's so important for
white to keep as many minor pieces as
possible because white does have the
space Advantage you were talking about
the break on the queen side a very
thematic B5 idea but Jose Martinez goes
for another thematic idea which is to
try to get play on the king side he
pushes the G Pawn forward you have to
watch out for this G Pawn from G5 going
one step ahead to G4 really cramping
down on the king side gaining more space
isolating that E4 Pawn making sure that
the F Pawn remains a backward Pawn on F2
I really like this aggressive play by
Jose and it really puts Dennis into the
think right now two minor two sets of
minor pieces off the board in these
structures it does favor Black uh
David Y and uh exactly this bonon is all
about trading once at a pieces so you're
not struggling for space as we mentioned
in the other game and uh talking
fighting for space he's been stopped on
the king side he's now throwing pawns
forward on the queen side I was going to
say Black's uh pawn move Pawn to G5 it's
The Sweet Spot is active and it's
strategic uh it's kind of playing
dynamically but also stopping White's
main plan of pushing a pawn to F4 for
good but now it's all about the other
side of the board and uh how does Dennis
react there a bit of a positional threat
to capture on C5 due to the fact that
blacks pinned on the B file this Rook
undefended on the back rank ideally you
would love to move this bishop out the
way therefore always connect your Rooks
if you can but White's Queen also
peering down at this Pawn uh a bit
awkward I've got to say I think Dennis
has chosen the right moment to strike so
um I love what uh Jose bam I keep saying
J bam instead of Jose but what he's been
doing so far but still questions to
answer and he trades off and this is a
high responsibility decision because now
he's left with a backward Pawn forever
and he has to back this up with active
piece play idea I guess Robert is to
activate his pieces to uh better
outposts taking control of some key dark
squares why not and I think a critical
point is that this A5 move it challenges
the white
and says where are you going so look at
Dennis he backs it up and so quickly
does Jose play Knight to D7 look at how
he's played G5 to stop White's F4 Pawn
push then playing on the queen side so
Jose understands the structure he
understands where his pieces belong and
White's pieces look pretty optimally
placed but that's not good enough you
need to come up with plans rather than
just say hey this is a good aesthetic I
I'm feeling nice what is the next plan
for white I'm still looking at a way to
try and push the pawn to F4 but it does
open up both Kings it's not going to be
a one-sided attack both players need to
watch out at this stage
Tanya you're absolutely right about that
and I think there are two plans in these
positions uh Robert for white you either
try to push F4 which is a double-edge
sword because you open the G line for
both you could do that with either
shifting your Rook from D1 to F1 to
support the advance or perhaps the queen
could fall back to D2 or E3 the main
idea is to defend this F4 Square try and
push black Queen's back uh Queen back
and then expand in the center the other
idea that I see for white is maybe
another shift the more strategic plan to
try to double up on the dline making
sure that Black's Knight on D7 stays as
a defensive piece I see that Dennis has
gone for Queen to E3 he wants to get F4
in and he does it this is blowing up
this is opening up and it's not a
one-sided attack as you pointed out
because the G file opens for both
players we're perhaps going to see a
trade on F4 and then the queen Falls
falls back the king will shift to h8 and
who lands on the G line
first yeah it's just a race now it's
going to be mutual attacks I was looking
at the queen side for the last few moves
Tanya and then uh suddenly attention
switches Elsewhere for both players and
um I just want to talk as well as this
one really starts to heat up about uh
that previous game surely if you're Jose
Martinez you get frustrated Dennis lazic
just never loses and uh now he's the one
on the attack he's the pushing do you
think Jose is happy with the outcome
here especially as his position is kind
of hanging by threat E5 now in the air
it's uh it's lurking what's going
through his mind
Robert that he's probably a bit scared
E5 is a tremendous threat it hits the
queen on F6 but it also tries to Spring
free some pass Pawns in the center and
Black's pieces are pretty well placed
the Rook on B8 it protects the pawn in
front of it the Rook on E8 it tries to
counter White's ideas in the center the
queen on F6 the Knight on C5 they're
very clearly on active squares so now it
was The Bishop's turn so he plays Bishop
D7 he kind of had to not that it was the
only good move but Tanya as I look at
this white is playing E5 whether you
like it or not so at least create a
counter threat and that pawn on A4 that
one is in the line of fire from Black's
pieces
now this is really heating up E5 on the
board black is going for the queen side
with the pawn weaknesses White NOW steps
away with the King it looks like it's
going to be White's Rook that's going to
be arriving first on the G line black
has to take a moment out I don't believe
you can capture on A4 right now Rook G1
just looks far too menacing Dennis the
Menace you give him Rook G1 and that's
going to be trouble it might be time for
Jose to step aside with his own King to
h8 to try to dodge all these ideas along
the G
file say king h8 T and I agree it might
well be the best move but I don't say it
with confidence because it's also
sitting on an open diagonal poten
potentially and uh I wonder whether in
the near future he's going to try and
drop his Queen on the D3 Square just at
any cost it might come at the cost of a
pawn and uh it's just more important to
survive with your king get those Queens
off at any cost um that would be the
other main move on my radar at least
right now for Martinez three minutes on
the clock if you're getting attacked you
have to maintain some time and there we
go Queen to D3 I think a good practical
decision uh evaluation Bar says no of
course but at least now with Queens off
he will live to fight another day and uh
as we saw in the previous game when the
clock takes down he's really strong in
that L latter phase um so decision to
survive from it but I think I understand
why this gets a question mark just like
Jose exploited a game ago I think the
fact that the queen is loose on D3
allows white to play Knight to E4 now
and you can't touch that Knight on e4 oh
he he missed it but Knight E4 was
Untouchable that Knight would have
landed on F6 with a check against the
king the rook and the bishop all at once
so that Skirmish that those tactical
sequences there were favorable for
Dennis but we know it's in his style to
play the positional choice if he can so
I I think that his position isn't bad in
the live board underneath me here but
this would have been aggressive and
playing for a bit more uh it comes with
risk that's for sure loose pawns
everywhere but it also would have been
playing with strength with the
initiative so I think Tanya at this
stage we just saw the Queens come off
the board
a mistake was made but it was overlooked
so really was it a mistake at
all uh to me the big question is conl
just now pick up the A4 Pawn I see that
the D6 Pawn might be hanging after you
give a check on G3 but at the end of it
once you give a check white black side
steps The Rook on D1 is hanging as well
so you can't immediately capture D6 you
probably have to trade the bishop for
the Knight first it just feels like the
awn can be really dangerous here for
Jose Martinez it might be the moment to
start looking for chances because even
if white immediately not immediately
eventually captures on D6 that white
Pawn on D6 David will be a weakness
maybe we can just show it Knight takes
Bishop Knight takes Knight Rook to G3
check King moves this time I think f8
would be the square of choice and then
you gra on D6 firstly D6 is a weak Pawn
but also look at that A5 Pawn it's a
protected pass Pawn a good good Knight
on A4 this end game could be very
dangerous for white David definitely
White's Bishop is not playing a role and
uh I think the most important Point as
you called it Tanya this is not a real
uh strength uh maybe the stronger Pawn
is the one behind it tying down a black
Rook once it takes the four uh runner
the front D Pawn but yeah essentially
it's all about Black's queenside
majority and I actually think black has
a pretty clear path to victory in this
game white with no counterplay at all so
difficult difficult decision here for
Dennis lazic let's go back I don't think
he should get greedy instead he plays
the move Rook to G1 and uh he's going
for the black king somehow but uh but
how wow Pawn to E6 trying to deflect
away this Black Knight the Black Knight
is forced to defend its Bishop so you
cannot take too many times on this E6
square and now he's aiming just for a
pawn storm Pawn to E6 followed by Pawn
to F5 F forward here and um at least
he's mixing it up I think a really
clever decision there from Dennis Robert
I watch Jose shake his head he
overlooked this move E6 I'm shaking my
head too because it's a pawn race this E
Pawn accompanied by an F Pawn that looks
scary but as T mentioned there's an A
and A B Pawn for black and those pawns
can Rumble forward too so I'm worried
about the black king I'm worried about
all of these past p and I'm also worried
about Jose's clock Tanya we keep talking
about how he's doing well on you know
even in time scrambles this is very
tactical so you are going to have to be
extra careful here to survive this
position against Dennis
laic couldn't agree more with that but
we've seen Jose just how accurate he is
with little time on on the clock even if
the position's really complicated and
although White's the one who's down upon
and yes we pointed out that a passer but
this last move by Dennis that's
terrifying White's got a protected past
Pawn on E6 now and our computer it's
showing the best move the Knight
rerouting itself to D4 wire E2 attacking
that F5 weakness I'm picking white right
now despite Jose being the one who's
Pawn up I think black's got to be the
one who's who has to be care in this
position but David he chooses another
plan he wants to put this bishop on
H5 love it The Bishop's coming in um it
might just come in anyway Bishop to H5
plunk it down on F7 and there's going to
be all sorts of checkmating ideas around
the black king um the allseeing
overlords the Silicon overs there the
computers say Knight to E2 first even
stronger and uh again same plan Knight
back and once it lands on E2 comes
forward into D4 beautiful Outpost and
this is the big weakness in Black's
position the F5 porn
I think Jose needed to bite the bullet
and just trade off pawns earlier because
this one yes he's blocked up white for a
move or two but it's going to fall in
the long term instead Dennis puts his
Bishop on H5 very natural move and again
the blue arrow indicates Black's best
move by far you need to trade off one
set of Rooks but I'm going to say that's
not obvious um it's not instinctive you
normally would want to keep a rook
behind pass pawns throw this Pawn down
the board it's simply to stop White's
checkmating ideas if you allow this
bishop to land on F7 and the white Rook
to slide over to G3 then black will be
doomed so you need to trade before it's
too late Rook to G8 only way to save
this game he's got 30 seconds left
though Jose I don't envy his chances
Robert no and you can see it on his face
and look he was Bishop E8 the evaluation
it goes all the way up and I think it's
because white can bring the knight in
and there Dennis goes Knight D4 hitting
F5 going to C6 with checkm threats the
loose Pawns in Black's position I just
feel like they're going to drop off a
rook goes to G5 as well if you want to
win F5 directly this looks painful as
the White's pawns feel faster than
Black's Tanya David I'm looking at this
and I'm thinking Dennis he's got this
under
control he's the race and you're ahead
you've got a head start PA on E6
Tanya and Robert this is something You'
always said it's not about the quantity
of Pawns it's about the quality of Pawns
and that pawn on E6 is is worth more
than just the one Pawn a deficit that
white has right now look at the peace
activity Dennis also up on the clock
Jose shaking his head he's down to 30
seconds the F5 Pawn is falling the
Knight is coming in the a pawn hasn't
really gone down the board that move
E6 Robert I think that was the moment
that it changed the game it changed the
Dynamics and it took Jose by big
surprise the key word is dynamic it
changed the game from one where both
players were little pushing pawns trying
to gain the upper hand and then made it
Dynamic and look at this position as
David draws the arrows David you take it
away this is such a nice find from
Dennis to secure Victory it seems he's
calculated so deeply he's going to throw
his Knight out the way with a check now
a fork clearing the path for the
coronation of his eorn he's going to
make a queen this is game over beautiful
there from Dennis lazovic he spotted it
all a mile away this is just wonderful
play Queen coming Jose Martinez is going
to resign and there we go Dennis gets
the win beautiful play wow we're all so
impressed right now just incredible
Precision by disis lazic starting from
that move E6 amazing conversion and
spectacular end with that move Knight G6
Au cannot stop the pawn from queening
and Dennis lavic takes the first win of
this match which means that for Jose he
needs to win a game to level the score
and meanwhile FV is about to bounce back
in his match against Magnus Robert oh a
long time ago in a position far away it
looked like Magnus had everything under
control but look at the evaluation bar
but also the last couple moves it is is
two extra pawns for fed of but maybe
Magnus could use one of his pawns as a
distraction and try to grab a couple of
his own a reminder to all of our newer
audience members out there if white just
has a knight and a king against an enemy
King there is no way to check me so
that's what black is aiming for get rid
of all of White's pawns even if it cost
you a knight and that's what fedos will
avoid so David do you see any chances
you know how to grind like a grand
master can Magnus try anything he can
and he is trying everything possible
to draw this game to give up the Black
Knight give up the black pawns for all
of White's remaining foot soldiers there
but computer's indicating actually only
one winning move fed doesn't find it he
had to give a night check first and
actually maybe needed to keep more pawns
alive because suddenly Magnus as you
said is going to use the G Pawn as a
distraction and then the black king is
just going to eat up White's remaining
pawns the black king is going to come in
and some easy targets now that's uh oh
I've jinxed him commentator's curse why
is that had a mistake
and he's got away with it he's going to
come in now fed have actually could have
given a check we'll show this later that
was a beautiful idea to maintain a
winning position robbert and you only
see that because the evaluation bar is
off to the side nobody is looking for it
David will show it after the game but
now we see the result should not be in
too much doubt you go after the white
pawns and that was another great move by
the way King B5 that eliminates any
questions instead of trying to bring
your king away from that pass Pawn I
think you guys spotted it maybe with the
evaluation bar but I think Magnus
spotted it we saw him react right now I
think he knows that there was that
moment that fedos have missed the win
and now it's everything under control
for Magnus he survives it he doesn't
only have the incredible ability to win
winning positions but he also has the
ability to survive lost positions and
Magnus Carlson does it again saves the
game and it ends in a draw but there was
a moment David when FV could have won
that end
game he could could indeed have won that
end game Magnus Houdini Carson though
gets away with it yet again and I just
wanted to very briefly show if we have
the opportunity fed pondering uh looking
at his missed opportunities but first
this is the breakdown Tanya these are
the scores on the doors and Dennis lvic
with a spectacular win with the white
pieces takes the lead in his match
meanwhile Magnus Carlson survives a big
scare in that night and pawn end game
fed almost bounced back but almost is
not good enough against the world number
one
David no not enough so close though
Robert so so close but against the top
players you have to put the chances in
the back of the net and here I just
wanted to point out Knight to E5 check
was the winning move and uh in order to
Simply deflect away the black king but
this is another story let's show the
more spectacular of the two wins after a
trade of Pawns he brought his King
forward and Magnus actually slipped up
here he brought uh his Pawn forward and
then went straight in with King to D5 he
needed to first throw away the pawn
Force the black king uh the white king
sorry even further away and then go with
the Knight to start taking the white
pawns with a draw miraculously three
pawns down instead however after King
dd5 the miracle win Knight to E3 check
as pointed out by the computer and after
King takes Pawn you throw the Knight
away as well deflect this Black Knight
and look how far away the Black Knight
is from this Pawn Knights are the worst
at stopping Corner pawns these blank BS
and white would have made a new Queen on
the game One Missed opportunity there
for fed and Magnus gets away with
it so close yet so far for V fedos he
still needs to needs a win to bounce
back in this match and is also the same
story line for Jose Martinez who had a
heartbreaking loss in the last one so
much in control but Dennis lavic scoring
a big win we've got a big game three
action coming right up don't go anywhere
as the players will be
[Music]
back
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding LC since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially exciting
be sure to watch all the games on the
live stream at chess.com and on our
freestyle.lil and fascination of Chess
in a completely new life
our once magnificent Kingdom of Chess
lays now in ruins our King slain but
some say that a new ruler will come and
restore the realm to its former glory
solve puzzles fight epic battles and
earn gold swords and Scrolls full of
Chess wisdom on your way to reclaiming
the throne d download the app today and
this month only face off against your
favorite Kingdom character Bots only on
chess.com
[Music]
St
it's always a pleasure to be joined by
one of my favorite people on the planet
none other than Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley Maurice how you doing my friend
yo Robert what's good what's good you
know I'm so happy to talk to you we
haven't chatted about the Nicks of late
so happy to be on the show we could talk
about that for hours though so let's get
back to the
action well Maurice the Knicks are up to
big things but I hear that you're up to
big things as well so what do you got
for us what what do you have to announce
for
everybody well we had a special contest
that we announced back in in uh November
SL December seems so long ago now uh it
is the create your own course contest
and chessable of course loves to get
everybody the entire Community involved
and they had 73 submissions and three
different languages we had six English
language finalists and I was naturally
going to be presenting the winner I'm
going to be giving the voice over for
the winner but it turns out we had
something really special only this time
happening in fact we have two winners
and that's the Shocker two courses were
such high quality that we could not
distinguish it we said you know what
give it to them both show them both love
this is just for the work that they've
put in and so we're excited to be able
to do that and and uh announce the two
winners make them very happy well it
sounds like extra work for you as well
how has it been working with the ches
team how's this experience been for you
it's been extraordinary going to
Barcelona on a regular basis how am I
supposed to complain about that I am
going as well next week so Barcelona has
been like my new city I might as well
move like you to Europe or get on that
side of the pond because I'm always over
there but the chessable team is just
fantastic uh all the people who helped
me so much to make just super
comfortable so I love working with chess
in the courses that I've already created
and looking to create many many more
well I love to hear that so without
further Ado why don't you tell me who
are the winners and what are the courses
you'll be
making indeed let's get right to it the
first winner is Advanced chess patterns
by Benedictine and we all know that
patterns are important in chess all of
us know our standard patterns and he did
make a course Before Common chess
patterns but he has upped his game now
and brought the patterns that gms's like
a Robert has with SP spot in a
millisecond I saw you spot that Knight
E4 in that game followed by Knight F6
that inzo that lazaric should have seen
those kind of things are what are going
to be in that course and then the other
one the killer Kings by Icebreaker and
this is about the Kings doing big things
the king marching down the board like a
Nigel short walk or a petan King march
to the left when you it's like what is
that about but you know you're nodding
your head like yeah I know that one but
yes we're going to show that to the fans
as well also castling to win you know
those are always exciting when you
Castle Queen side pick off a rook on B2
maybe Castle King side all those are
examples of how the king can be used as
a fighting piece and those courses were
so welld designed well thought through
that we just thought it was necessary to
make both of them winners well I love
that those both sound like excellent
courses and Maurice in your Hall of Fame
speech you said that you the the game of
chess's biggest fan so what advice would
you give to fans of the game who may
want to create their own course me how
do you see that
process you know nowadays it's so much
easier back in the day it was all about
books but now that we have so much
digital material if you have an idea
that you are a fan of something that
really tickles your fancy for me it was
chess geometry my very first chessable
course secrets of Chess geometry which
has been a runaway success the the idea
of geometry in chest it's so beautiful
when you see all kinds of these
geometric Maneuvers zigzags dominations
and the like so when you have an idea
nowadays you can take a database and
filter that database to show you comb
through that database to show you the
way your idea can be presented in pure
form there are millions of games and in
those millions of games they're going to
be 100 200 examples of whatever idea you
consider to be one of your favorites and
that's what I would would recommend come
up with an idea just learn how to filter
it through a through databases like
chess base and once you do that you're
on your way wow I mean you couldn't have
said it any better so it sounds like
Maurice you recommend that teachers and
those who want improve they maybe get
and enjoy the waiting list for the
courses that you're about to
make yeah I would say so there are a lot
of quality chessable courses they keep
going to them out it looks like many
times a month but they're definitely
going to be topics that you're intrigued
by for me it's less like the openings I
don't say Chessa is great at studying
openings nowadays remember how painful
it was for us Robert back in the day
trying to comb through opening lines
nowadays it's just spoonfed to you so
that is definitely there but I have to
say I have a special preference for
those middle games and especially those
end games where you see these weird
things happening that idea that was
missed by federay of that Knight C2
check followed by A6 and the Knight
can't get back it's not just just that
it was a Side Pawn it's just the exact
setup of this Knight on the second Rank
and a Pawn on the sixth the Knight just
can't get back to catch it those kind of
geometric concepts are just beautiful
and those are my favorites whenever
somebody does something like that on
chess well those are your favorites as I
said you're one of my favorite people on
the planet your energy is contagious and
you may be one of the chess's biggest
fans but I'm one of your biggest fans
ever since I was a kid we'll catch up
we'll catch up soon of course man but
continue doing what you're doing we love
to see all the content you're bringing
there and well continue being a fan and
watching the champion chest I'm a fan of
what you all are doing absolutely you
David and Tanya you are killing it I you
know I've retired from chess commentary
on a regular basis but I there's no loss
because you all are keeping it at
extremely high level so keep up the good
work well thank you my friend thank you
for passing the torch and we are heading
back to the Champions chess tour you
heard Grandmaster Maurice Ashley he is
creating his two courses but a course
can be written just about about these
matches here in the Champions chest Tor
the chessable Masters is our first Lego
season David and Tanya you're back and
we'll be back with a one and a half half
lead for both Magnus Carlson and Dennis
lavic and the games they're getting
underway Rober the games are underway
we've seen our story storyline Magnus
Carlson survived in that last game these
endgame geometry that Maurice was
pointing at so beautiful such a big Miss
by fedf he starts with the black pieces
if Magnus gets the dub in this one if he
wins with white it's match over for fedf
so he needs to make sure things stay
under control and speaking of things
staying under control I think this is an
opening that needs to be broken down
David Knight takes E4 offering white to
pick up that Knight it looks like it's
for free it looks like it's for free
this is uh the four night Scotch as we
call it one of the most drawish openings
if you believe top ground Masters but
not this move fed save throwing a knight
away I'm just going to show a quick
action replay uh before it's too late
there we go of Black's last move let's
go back a couple of turns it was here
after Knight takes D4 Knight takes E4 a
big shock the main move in that position
being uh for example Bishop out to B4
but uh instead Knight takes E4 on the
board and uh Magnus wow he goes for a
variation uh that's forcing the Queens
off again just slow Action Replay here
Knight takes Knight would have been met
by a couple of different moves but Queen
E7 is one of them you pin and you do win
back the material due to this line and
the White Queen being tied down to the
White Knight in the center let's catch
up with the game however uh just a
temporary night sacrifice but Magnus
instead playing a different variation
trading everything off and uh let's just
bring that game back for you and Wow
Let's see he's pieced down if I'm to
trust the live board right now I'm going
to try and fix uh what we've got in
front of us but um level material Robert
looks at least to my eyes like Magnus
has been caught off guard in these early
stages well as we catch up with the live
position the Queens are off and that
doesn't mean that the game just
concludes so uh we see underneath me
here that the uh King for black is out
in the open the king for white is uncle
and will not legally be able to Castle
but while I have a quick second I I do
want to shout out marce more time I said
that I was one of Maurice's biggest fans
it's true I can't believe I'm saying
this publicly but Tanya I know you'll
appreciate this when I was a kid Maurice
was at a tournament playing doing
analysis all that stuff and I was too
nervous to go up to him and ask for his
autograph I was like nine years old and
my mom she's ever the Bold character she
just storms right over to where Maurice
is like my son he's a big fan of yours
can he get a an autograph I don't know
if we have a photo I'll have to ask my
parents but ever since I was a kid I've
had so much respect for Mar honor to
call him a friend and now that we have
said that I'm happy to go back into the
chess where there's a check against the
black king out in the
open the deadly well I was going to say
deadly it's not that deadly the black
king cam Retreat I'm just so used to all
those King Marchers Maurice name dropped
some of those great king walks of all
time and I don't think we'll see the
black king continue its Journey Down the
board out into the open uh it's well
hopefully learned a lesson from Maxi
Vash gra King we'll see the black king
surely just Retreat and drop back there
we go to safety and now the game will
take a slower turn blacks Bishops can
come out to very nice sensible squares I
think roughly level position the
fireworks in this game happened right
off the bat really really early and uh
yeah just uh before we move on from
Maurice I just want to shout out to him
as well I remember one of my first chess
memories watching his commentary 1994
those Intel rapid tournaments where he
was commentating with Danny King and
that got me into this beautiful game so
uh big shout out to one of our chess
Heroes and in the meantime Dan Dan Tanya
even but David I'm GNA join both of you
in that I um I'm also a big Maurice
Ashley fan I think he knows it I've
always been so inspired by him I've seen
him commentate I've worked alongside him
and I think of course he's a he's a
really strong player was a really strong
player but even his commentary it's it's
been so amazing to watch how he changed
that the energy that he got into the
game it influenced I think so much of
Chess broadcast and Robert I don't know
if you remember this but for me one of
my first commentating experiences was
millionaire chess and a chance that
Maurice gave me uh all the way from
India he called me and you and I covered
that event together and it's one of my
core memories and I enjoyed it so much
and uh yeah I think everyone in chat
everyone here commentating we're all
Maurice Ashley fans mauce you're awesome
except for that one kid in the video
where Maurice slaps all the pieces off
the board I feel like I've seen that a
couple of times where he's imitating
Searching for Bobby Fisher but uh we are
in the midst of a heated match between
Magnus Carlson and Vladimir fedos so
sorry for distracting I just wanted to
give uh Maurice that shout out and it's
always great to be joined by him but I
don't think it's always great to be
playing Magnus Carlson when you slip up
in a winning position and you start
kicking yourself that's when Magnus I
feel like he is feeling his most
confident he's upset that he allowed
fedos of all that play but now he says I
can survive even that terrible end game
and what do we make of this David I mean
there are so many tactics in this
position even without Queens on the
board some loose pawns some uh open
lines against each king would you say
that Magnus or fedos is happier to be in
this position I think Magnus is happier
that he's still ahead in the match uh
because he really was uh kind of
fortunate to survive that previous game
fed deserved the win there uh but as you
say you cannot relax against Magnus
Carson I was writing this off as level
drawish but not drawn yet and uh like
you say tactics in the air wow including
this move I was gonna say there were
tactics like Bishop takes F2 which would
have walked into a pin on the last move
but Magnus first deflecting away the
black king forcing the king to move in
order to win the black Bishop so
actually a level trade in the end but
Magnus now has the opportunity to
capture this Pawn to hope that he gives
his opponent an isolated Pawn
something to work with potentially long
term in the game isolated pawns tend to
be weak in their games with Rooks so um
okay mixed feelings here at Magnus he
could if he's feeling safe just Retreat
his Rook back but then black will take
on his terms on the C4 Square giving
white the isolated Pawn so um I'm going
to stick to my original evaluation say
it should be a draw with best play but
we all know Magnus that endgame touch
those end game skills um FV still needs
to bring his best in order to counter
and uh I suggest starting with a rook
move to win this Pawn yeah don't take it
back with a pawn he plays it and uh he
keeps the Integrity of his Pawn chain
intact connected pawns tend to be better
than isolated ones um Tanya draw
prediction here or am I wrong I really
like that last move by feder I think
it's a key move to keep the balance
going and look at this Magnus makes sure
that he can really trade on D5 on his
terms get that isolated Queen pawn
something to play for long term game one
that Magnus won it was it was the Queens
got traded early on and yet he kept
fighting he got the dub in and this one
as well I have no doubts that he's going
to try and create
something the one thing that white is
aiming for is to force black to take on
D5 the bishop falls back to D6 Rook goes
to G5 G7 is hanging this is getting
tactical because black has yet to
capture on D5 fos Robert he needs to be
careful right now and we see that
there's only one move here that holds
the balance for black black Rook to H7
it's a very natural move protecting your
Pawn next to your king that's loose and
keeping contact with the H5 Pawn so
fedos of I mean he just outplayed Magnus
in an end game so I know that I often
lead the charge talking about how strong
Magnus is in the end game and it is true
fedos I he had his chances and maybe
he'll have chances in this one but while
he sits and thinks why don't we zoom out
for a second because we could have a
winners bracket finalist after this game
on the left hand side of our screen
Dennis lvic is up one and a half to half
two and a half points sees you sail
through and with the black pieces in
this position oh David I'm looking at
this one I'm thinking I would love to
have the space that Dennis has been able
to secure for
himself he's one connect for my favorite
game other than chess he's got this
phenomenal porn chain and uh this porn
chain not only is it beautiful but it
blunts this uh this dark Square Bishop
this I'm I mean calling it a bishop
feels wrong somehow doesn't roll off the
tongue when a piece like this one s
sadly staring down at a bunch of Pawns
also looking at the white king it's not
going to feel safe anytime it can no
longer Castle King side the white Rook
has moved on G1 doesn't really feel
comfortable castling on the other flank
either because you've pushed a pawn out
to B4 meaning the king will be really
Airy long term so I like his space
Dennis lavic my question Tanya what does
white try to do to break the bind to
break this connect for porn
formation it's really hard this say that
to break a pawn chain you have to attack
the base but the base is far behind on
C7 it's so hard to get to that you are
thinking about ideas like perhaps A4
expanding on the queen side maybe an
eventual B5 B6 we will see that pawn
chain the base being into trouble but
right now the first thing that Jose has
to think about is taking care of the
king side his own King position as well
and I like this move by Dennis he gets
rid of the active Bishop that was on B3
the light squat Bishop with White's King
in the center Dennis is not only eyeing
the kingside advance but a potential D5
break to really start asking questions
white isn't feeling safe on the queen
side with the pawns Advanced once D5
comes in the center opens up as well so
Bishop B6 D5 ideas in the air I'm liking
Black's position here Robert one reason
I would potentially refrain from D5 even
though I think objectively it's a great
move is it does give white a little bit
more breathing room that White's pieces
are cramped and he goes for D5 and the
evaluation bar it doesn't react so I as
you said as I said great decision it's a
very strong move from uh Dennis but I
think practically speaking then now some
of White's pieces will get a little bit
more space because when you're cramped
you want to trade so I would take this
Pawn on D5 try to quickly put my knight
on e4 and at least I start to see space
some ideas some threats Dennis doesn't
mind ton it you didn't mind either and
David well now the question is what do
you think about that latest decision are
you also a fan like Tanya and Dennis
himself
I say well I would say yes but it's all
about this bishop um I think here um I
still fa black I think all of us would
purely because of this piece purely
because of the fact that the white king
can't Castle but I'm quing two minds
Robert you probably heard the hesitation
on my voice because at least now white
has one compensating factor it's a
beautiful Outpost uh on e4 one that you
can never really challenge um so yeah
it's kind of mixed feelings it feels
like denn is a bit impatient now he
senses the Finishing Line in this match
he's one point ahead a win with black
here would end it on the spot no need to
go the distance in the fourth game and
he's trying to rush but he doesn't need
to he's got the long-term Advantage he
has to just ensure now that white isn't
able to for example push this Pawn
forward move this Rook out the way
relocate this bishop to a new diagonal
it's going to take four five moves but
uh Dennis cannot allow the opponent that
luxury and okay another question mark
attached to this move I think it's
actually quite a healthy one the Knight
on the rim wasn't great
but uh now what is the idea what's he
going to do if white simply sets up this
barricade of Pawns Tanya do you like it
as much as you did just two three moves
ago for black I'm going to be honest I
thought it was an idea that you want to
prepare a little bit first get your Rook
into the game perhaps transfer the
knight from C6 to a better Square maybe
bring back the Knight on H5 then has
decided to go for it immediately and
this E4 Square it really looks like a
stronghold right now looks like
everything is under control that said
I'm still surprised with the question
Mark awarded to Knight to F6 because it
feels like the most natural move the
Knight on H5 isn't doing anything you
want to trade off your opponent's most
active piece in the center David F3 on
the board and the big question is how
does black follow up to me it looks
natural that you want to start placing
the Rooks into the center of the board
you want to get one Rook to d8 you want
to get the other Rook to E8 but then you
have to watch out for ideas like B5
meanwhile Dennis just decides to get rid
of the minor
pieces if you take with the Knight I
think he wants to jump in with Knight
593 sorry I was just quickly going to
note that the other game between Magnus
Carlson and Vladimir FV has concluded as
a draw there wasn't much to it a few
pieces came off Magnus still sitting in
his chair probably looking over that
opening before getting into the next
game using that game review feature but
for fedos sa I think when he clicks on
game review he'll say all right I played
like a boss nearly perfect chest from
the black side he was never in danger so
all of our attention will be back to the
left hand side of our screen between
Jose Martinez and Dennis lazic at least
until the fourth game because there will
be a fourth game between Magnus and
Vladimir but for now I'm starting to see
Jose with some chances I know the
evaluation bar is suggesting that Dennis
is still in charge but I just don't feel
like the last couple moves have gone his
way so David I mean do you see any
specific plans that black can execute to
sort of punish White's King in the
center or is wh King actually going to
feel safe and sound or whoa apparently
there was a big blunder waa wow double
question mark and we see it we're given
a big clue here by the computer the blue
arrow black can pretty much win on the
spot he needs to pounce now it's a one
off opportunity Dennis look at that on
camera frowning Jose Martinez shaking
his head they both spotted this Knight
takes pawn and let's show this on the
board if it happens this is quite simple
tactics here now I think you bunch of
moves win but this is a simple pin
you've bagged a couple of Pawns in the
process if white tries to defend then
you unleash the bishop this beast from
afar Pawn to E4 and uh the bishop
uncaged simply wins material you're
going to win either the White Knight or
the white rook in the corner this is
resign and it's simple tactics Jose
Martinez Ed it slip and there we go it's
on the board Knight takes C3 look at
that sips his water Dennis lazic double
exclamation mark from the game review
he's just as simple as that I was about
to say things have got better for white
the best position he's seen in a long
time but not that move a big blunder
there Rook to H1 too slow you always
have to be vigilant for tactics these
one-off shots and there we go
resignation game over not an Abrupt
finish to this match it's game over and
it's match over Dennis lazovic advances
through while for Jose Martinez he will
go down to the losers bracket and what a
turnaround it has been for the
17-year-old he was in big trouble the
one big Miss in game one he block
but being resourceful held on to that
one and he wins game three Knight
tactics all around Knight G6 got him the
first win Knight C3 got him the second
win what a performance it has been so
far in the cheser bow Masters by Dennis
lazic we have our first Winner's
finalist Dennis lazic the 17-year-old he
continues his resounding success from a
year ago he wins his match against Jose
Martinez two and half half meanwhile on
the right hand side Magnus Carlson still
has a game four against feda Vladimir he
proved that in game two he could get the
upper hand with white we'll see if he
can do it a second time but David how
impressed are you with 17-year-old
Dennis
Lai he might just be on the edge of 17
but he is a phenomenon uh just the
killer instinct spotting that tactic
within a few seconds you saw the frown
that kind of look of confusion on
Dennis's face kind of disbelieving that
his strong grandmas opponent would
blunder but the confidence with which to
execute that tactic to force res
he's not lost a game yet since division
one started he's uh yeah just amazing
amazing player maybe a future world
champion if he keeps up this uh this
type of form but first we do have
another clash in the winners bracket and
I believe that's about to start soon
yeah in just a couple of minutes Magnus
Carlson and fedia will take on their
final rapid game but the boy of the
moment has to be Dennis lazic we've been
talking about his strategic strength how
good he is at end games how good he is
in his opening preparation positional
fights but today we've seen that when
Dennis gets those tactical opportunities
he can be super sharp Robert is it fair
to say that he's developing into a
player who has a very Universal style I
I think that Dennis lazaric he's known
for his opening prowess he has a sound
repertoire and a very high level one I
think there's been a lot of comparisons
to him as being Wesley so 2.0 he doesn't
necessarily take risks but he is able to
strike if you give him the opportunity
and so laic he is improving he is
growing before our very eyes and he has
become a top level Grandmaster in the
Champions chess tour and now he awaits
the winner of this match between
Vladimir fedos and Magnus Carlson and we
are off in game
four we're off and fedos needs to strike
it's a must-win game for him David he
starts with the white pieces it's a
nimel take it away
that's a nimzo Indian defense where
black brings out the bishop very early
and now Magnus challenging for the
center uh White's last move putting the
queen on the C2 Square isn't regarded as
the most ambitious the most kind of
aggressive Line This is more positional
so bit of a surprise there and a trade
of Pawns in the center we're heading
back towards one of those carsbad type
structures and it looks like a m mix uh
mish mash I was going to say between the
nimso Indian and the Queen's Gambit
clined and uh there we go the white
Bishop just exerting pressure now along
this diagonal an awkward pin will Magnus
break the pin that's the big question if
he does he would do that with the move
Pawn to G5 but that would be risky in a
situation he just needs a draw um Robert
do you have any experience in this exact
position if so do you think this is a
good opening Choice by fed I think it is
I think this type of position is
definitely up his alley something he
enjoys and look at Magnus he understands
what's called for not often do we enjoy
bringing our Knight out in front of the
pawns but this is the trendy main line
where black goes after this bishop on G3
Pawn to H4 threatens to more or less
trap that Bishop it can go forward to E5
but you capture it and if you save this
bishop by pushing H Pawn yourself up to
H4 then the Black Knight jumps into E4
so I have seen this opening a number of
times it's a very tricky line I think
it's a bit too forcing though and that's
going to be the problem for Vladimir
doesn't create complications in a way
that are more difficult for Magnus to
navigate and you see Magnus he kind of
has like a you know frown on his face
for a second but I think it's just
because he's uncomfortable in his chair
not in the position Tanya I think we're
seeing Knight E4 next for Magnus we're
going to see the knight jump onto E4 and
then the bishop land on F5 right now
white needs to answer the question with
that Bishop on G3 hanging you really
don't want to recapture with the F Pawn
opening up the E file the E3 weakness he
falls back with the bishop now now black
has the opportunity for Magnus he can
jump on with Bishop F5 lining up the
bishop and the Knight and the queen with
potential ideas of discovered attacks
and I think for white you've got to
develop that Bishop from F1 on D3 if
black was to play Bishop F5
David fully agree white is actually
behind in development now uh White has
just been messing around with this
bishop it's moved several times White's
Queen a bit of a Target as you indicated
Tanya um but on the bright side you've
provoked the black pawns forward Black's
never going to feel entirely safe with
the king in the center or on the king
side and Magnus in the metime a bit of a
mysterious move I'm going to say is he
lining up some tactics against the white
king potentially in the center Black's
pieces flying out of the traps here
Black's Bishop wants to move as you
mentioned black wants to Castle on the
queen side as Magnus did successfully in
an earlier game but yeah this is uh
chaotic and I was skeptical at first
I've for got to say this uh solid
opening Choice from fed but it's really
come to life Magnus is uh not backed
down from the fight here and suddenly
Black's Pawn structure might well be
ruined in the next few turns um I just
wonder where the black king is going to
go where's the white king going to go
kind of lined up all directions all
these pieces against it um this is a
fiery really promising start to this
game Robert um already I see so many
tactics in the air I guess you do too oh
it's going to be a fun battle for these
two but they still are within the realm
of some predecessor games in fact yuang
Yi and the super Grand Master From China
played against Gregory oar
who is a very powerful player in his own
right and a renowned theoretician so the
bishop went out to B5 in this game a
little bit more aggressive both Kings
remain in the center and there are a lot
of loose pieces in particular the Knight
on C6 and then the White Knight on C3 so
yeah they attac Us in the air for sure
it looks scary for both sides there's
also Pawn tension between H4 and G5 at
any moment one of those pawns can be
captured so I am going to pass I'm just
going to talk talk about all these ideas
and say it's wild Tanya I mean this
looks scary for both but I think maybe a
little scarier for
white absolutely agree especially with
that last move Bishop F5 we've been
talking about this and I just want to
point out one of the tactics that are
possible we mentioned that white wants
that Bishop on D3 when black plays
Bishop F5 but now that Magnus has a
queen on E7 if you play Bishop D3
actually unpinning that Knight on C6
there might be big tactics Knight takes
D4 is the first move that comes to mind
you want to open up e takes D4 the queen
on E7 is suddenly the power piece knight
takes C3 maybe there are a better checks
in the position but Knight C3 looks like
it would be game over so in fact FIA
does not have the option to counter this
last move by Magnus with retreating his
own Bishop but David if that's if that's
not on the table how are you fighting
the threat of a night jump fos doesn't
care he literally doesn't care he plays
moving night to E two and wow this is a
big high responsibility move I guess the
idea just before we move away from the
analysis is if Knight to G3 which looks
really strong double attack against the
White Queen and against this rook in the
corner then white will take off this
Knight and if you recapture the White
Queen jumps out and it's Counterattack
time remember this Knight is hanging if
you take this Rook then the White Queen
actually feasts on this rook in the
corner due to a double attack so this is
uh kind of the essence of chess the
essence of tactics are all these double
attacks and this is kind of the epitome
this is kind of um a great demonstration
of where all the tactics start flying
and um this current position I actually
think Magnus needs to first take care of
his King before he gets too ambitious
with any tricks traps of his own um I
wonder whether that's just dodging
getting the king to a safer square off
this diagonal I wonder whether that's
biting the bullet castling into it as we
say getting the King hidden on the Longs
side but either way this is really
really heating up and uh what a what a
start for us he takes this Pawn instead
on H4 and now the blue arrow strikes
again Pawn to A3 that's by far one of
the most difficult moves I'm going to
say it looks like you just want to get
to safety with your king a slow pawn
move Robert is that surprising yeah it's
surprising because black has like five
different options that all look scary
for white to handle including Knight on
e4 takes Knight on C3 so this position
is very tricky I said it before and I'll
say it again I think it's trickier for
white just because many of the tactics
are seemingly hitting for in Black's
favor whereas white doesn't have that
many threats just the Knight on C6 that
can be piled up on so A3 good luck to
you and I just want to know one more
defensive move that black always has is
that Rook coming up to H6 or in this
case we see the blue arrow castling
Queen so David that was your suggestion
before and apparently it's the only move
that keeps the Edge from
black oh castling Queen side it's Brave
but it's got to be on his radar there's
multiple threats here including Queen
takes Pawn on D5 and castling Queen side
does defend against that it takes a
brave man though T A Brave player to uh
just kind of commit the King on a side
that is going to be wrecked ruined in
the near future this is such a difficult
position it's just so complicated and to
come to a decision right now it is
already a moment where you need to start
being precise uh as we've seen Queen B3
not an accurate move but from a
practical perspective it asks questions
I really like this idea that you
mentioned Robert of actually a rook lift
on the king side because I would hate to
destroy that pawn structure on the queen
side I want to go long Castle eventually
but whenever you take on C6 you want to
recapture with that Rook but the
question is does black have enough time
can actually black make the move Rook 86
just postponing castle for the sake of
the structure here
David possible but I'm reluctant to give
up the uh beautiful dewn the White Queen
then would be attacking this bishop as
well like you said time I think that is
the key word right now and that's why
moves like Castle's Queen side kind of
long-term strategically they're risky
they don't make that much sense but it's
all about saving time and Castle's Queen
side achieves multiple things in one go
you get your king to safety Magnus plays
it you protect your Pawn on D5
everything at once and you unpin your
knight now big threats of jumping out
this way maybe Knight A5 in the near
future um only now does fed say have
challenged the black bishop and
okay this one it feels like this is
going to be decided somehow by a
tactical shot Robert I'm not sure where
I'm not sure when it might not be for
another 1520 moves but it's that type of
position there are so many tactics in
the air and one of them is Tanya's idea
from earlier there are Knight takes D4
ideas that you have to be careful about
so Bishop takes Knight on C3 would be my
first step because the E file if that
knight from the white side gets out the
way there will be a direct shot so look
at Magnus he Scoops up this night here
FV he has to take with the pawn if he
takes with the Knight he loses and he
does just that but let's talk about an
open G file why don't we discuss that a
rook can slide to G8 now or in the near
future if you want to keep your Pawn
structure intact I already mentioned a
move like Rook H6 which not only defends
the queen side but allows you to double
on the Gile in a creative way so I think
that you can make multi-purpose moves
here if you're Magnus Carlson I don't
believe in White's attack I don't think
the black king is in real danger and I
think that the scorecard underneath the
board here one exclamatory move from
Magnus cast on Queen side a great
reaction and for fedos sometimes a
question mark one error it doesn't seem
like a big one but in a position where
you have to be accurate every single
turn to keep the initiative it can show
that the advantage heads in one player's
way and in this case it's Magnus so I
yeah I don't really know how Magnus is
going to respond here he has several
options but I just don't really believe
in any attack against the black king T
he's touching the four minute Mark so he
needs to make a decision quick because
there's still a lot of pieces on the
board uh and there's still a lot of
fight in this position left I completely
agree with you that now white doesn't
will not be probably given the chance to
actually destroy the pawn structure on
the queen side again I really like the
idea of Rook H6 and I think it's just
been played by Magnus really nice call
there just a really good concept that
you know we often think about developing
Rooks uh you want to move them sideways
but Rook lifts in these kind of
positions can be so multi-purpose you're
thinking about not only defending that
Knight on C6 but eventually attacking
White's kingside Pawn for FV his King is
feeling very unsafe I can't imagine a
safety on the queen side the F2 Pawn is
hanging King side looks equally
dangerous which doesn't only mean that
the king is unsafe but it also means
that the Rook on H1 remains out of the
game for a really long time here
David I I don't envy fed at all I think
the only thing going in White's favor
now is the clock um I was going to
comment on his camera he was leaning
back for a long time he looked a bit
kind of out of love with his position
and understand so but he needs to hustle
Magnus he's so hard to kind of throw off
balance he's you see it sometimes you
see Magnus get emotional you see him
shaking his head but it's so rare you
really have to kind of shock him with a
move even if it's not the best move just
throw something uh kind of throw a
spanner in the works but suddenly it's
all lining up and it's not turning out
well for white he's kind of forced
Magnus to play a move he wanted clock
situation is dramatic Magnus is lower
there but it feels like White's position
is so much harder to play than the
opponents andt I'm trying to find some
reason for fed to get optimistic I'm
must admit I'm struggling do you see any
in this position do you think he looks
uh happy at
all no he's definitely not happy because
he needs to win this game just to stay
alive up in the Winner's bracket if he
loses he's still in the tournament
that's the good news but we saw the
sharks that are down in the losers
bracket we watch Ali Raza fuja and Yanna
pishi make it through so it's not like
you know you get to the losers bracket
and suddenly things are easier and as
for the chess he makes a pawn push Pawn
to F3 and we saw the blue arrow it comes
back to us I don't even think that's the
only move here like if I'm being honest
I think that black has a number of moves
that keep him with a huge advantage and
a draw is good enough for Magnus he's
got the odds here so he could play it
safe he could play aggressively and of
course Tanya he finds the best move even
when there are five different good-look
options Magnus Carlson just always seems
to find the best move moves in positions
I don't know how he does it but to me it
looks like it was game three which was
fed's big Chance missing that
opportunity with that Knight coming back
in that night and pawn end game I think
it was game two I'm sorry I'm going to
correct myself game two with Knight E4
um and eventually giving up the night
for that awn moving forward that was a
golden opportunity missed by FV and
against the world number one when you
miss those opportunities they come far
few and rare it's very hard to bounce
back in this match and now this position
it's Magnus who's playing for
more yeah I have to agree and uh we saw
Magnus on the camera kind of Shifting
position again frowning wincing I think
he might be remembering game two as well
Tanya just uh these top players they're
such perfectionists um they want to kind
of have smooth sailing they want to have
bragging rights over the opponent but
look at this Magnus suddenly upping the
pace maybe he was just shifting position
suddenly he's going for this white king
and the pawn is going to capture on G2
any moment now and it's really
reminiscent of that game earlier where
fua was able to Checkmate his opponent
with a king out in the open um I really
really fear for fed's Life credit to Fed
Poker Face there on the camera but after
Pawn takes G2 attacking this rook in the
corner the white king is going to be
Shan of its protection and there's going
to be all sorts of sacrifices in the air
I'm looking at the F3 Square I'm looking
at this bishop jumping in later to E4 um
there are threats on white side um it's
all about the clock now for Magnus maybe
there's a lot to calculate right now but
definitely winning for black if he can
hold his nerve if he can uh can maintain
this level of accuracy we've shown
Robert White wow okay gives up the work
in the corner do you think we'll see an
under promotion we have seen it yes that
is always fun to play in a game and it
was necessary everyone because you have
to count Tempo by Tempo if you establish
a new Queen there you would lost both of
your Queens so he had to take and
promote to a knight because it's a check
and then he can save his Queen so as
David is showing this would have won for
white because both Queens would have
left the boards what a find by FV and a
quick response from Magnus I think fos
is doing the right thing when you AR in
a winner go down to losers bracket
moment you need to throw everything at
Magnus and at least we have it imbalance
and you Magnus has been grimacing
throughout this game White's King feels
a little bit safer so when there's a lot
at stake in each and every game players
do go wrong from time to time even
Magnus Carlson the number one player of
well more than the last decade so as I
look at this position Tanya I see that
black is well ahead the evaluation bar
it's not lying to us but do you see any
chances for white just because we do
have some material imbalances and
perhaps play in a different direction
the biggest chance of fedos would have
been if Magnus had the auto promote to
queen turned on in that moment zero
captured on H1 and that would have
changed the game but in under promotion
gets the job done Magnus Carlson is up
in exchange he's already up on the score
line he uh is dominating this game from
start to finish it looks like fedos with
the white pieces never really got going
on the queen side we see no attack
against Black's King white King's still
feeling a bit of pressure the Knight
falls back the F4 Bishop cannot be given
up uh but I do see the bishop on D3
lining up with The Rook on G6 David is
this more compli at than what meets the
eye at first I think so I think uh yes
it's complicated and yes it's imbalanced
that's the key for fed he cannot let it
be just a clearcut kind of a straight
linear variation that Magnus has to work
out and then it's over and then it's a
draw or a black wi he has to make it as
we mentioned earlier a bit muddy those
Waters he has to complicate the issue
and um I do love the white Bishops I'm
very biased my favorite piece those
Bishops magnus's favorite pieces I'll
give a secret there but uh in the
meantime okay Rook to G5 a really classy
move and if Rooks disappear I do fear
for fed of then he's just trying to
again simplify the equation Magnus
Carson and Rook to H6 the bar slides
down Robert what's happened here uh is
this a necessary kind of gamble by fed
what's he missed it is yeah he knew that
if he traded Rooks he had no winning
chances so he'd rather lose he wants to
go down swinging the Black Knight can
step back to E7 trades clearly favor
Magnus Carlson who's a head by material
and has the safer King so you're
removing Defenders from the white side
so this is it gets a question mark
because objectively it was a bad move it
hands white excuse me black a winning
Advantage but it you have to do it
because a draw is a loss so I think that
he made the right decision and what in
the world is
that wow double question about Magnus
Carlson what's he missed is he just
trying to simplify things he's not
losing evaluation bus says still better
for black
but I see the look of shock on your
face yeah I just saw the evalar rise up
we see that it's a blunder it looks like
a stunning move the idea is clear right
if white was to pick up the Knight on D4
he wants to take the Knight on F5 you
recapture with the bishop the queen
jumps onto the game it still looks
incredibly strong for black with the
Rook so active the queen on F5 the
bishop on G3 not really getting the job
done and look at this the computer says
the best move for white is actually not
to grab material to allow the activity
but actually just to push the pawn on
F4 that was must be what Mikus missed R
it well I think is hilarious that the
best move here is not even to take the
sacrific material but just push your
Pawn to shut in your own Bishop but that
shows how sad fed's position is and that
actually means that magus's decision it
deserves exclamation points not question
marks because what is F4 here I he might
play it but where are the winning
chances possibly going to come from for
Vladimir here I'm sorry nobody's playing
F4 here was that oh my
gosh oh that was commentator I'm putting
it on
that oh David you are you a surprised as
Tanya that he played F4 yes I'm glad
Tanya you jumped in before me one more
second and I would have said the same so
don't worry and F4 is such an ugly
positional move but it's based on
tactical reasons The Rook is trapped and
I think this is what Magnus
underestimated this is why that we saw
the bar sink even the one world number
one is human he didn't spot in advance
that The Rook could actually be left on
this Square F4 is a really classy move
but ultimately as the computer's
pointing out here King to B8 the Blue
Arrow showing that black is still fine
you just need to shuffle into the corner
always step towards the corner if you
Castle on the long side if you Castle
Queen side good tip for everyone but
still this is uncomfortable I'm gonna
say for Magnus Carson 40 seconds on the
clock a trapped Rook suddenly for the
first real time since we jumped in here
the nerves are be jangling Magnus he's
going to try and focus he plays the best
move of course he does he is the best
for a reason but it's going to be
uncomfortable he's got to untangle this
piece is a big problem long term and
Robert he's going for it now
fev and Magnus must have some kind of
attack against the white king and the
problem is the queen can't jump over the
Rook so I'm looking at Rook takes that
forward check some kind of sacrifice of
The Rook to go after the white king
they're not my pieces so I can give them
up and take it back but Magnus he's down
under 20 seconds he needs to find
something because Fed was threatening to
win
material and suddenly he goes for that
idea Robert he's given up a whole Rook
Magnus Carson but he's gambling he's got
20 seconds left now Magnus is a whole
piece down wow suddenly this has turned
he's living life on the edge the world
number one fed this is his
opportunity he drops back his King that
was a check now the black Rook surely is
going to dive into the position and uh
Magnus Stakes a high 15
seconds L control he has lost control
Magnus he needs 10 seconds now and the
good news of FV is that the bishop can
block the check on the second rank so
you don't end up losing material and
there's no back rank ideas because the
Knight is defending instead of The Rook
check Magnus gives a queen check but
white is up a whole piece right now you
could also snap up the Knight on E7 it's
a piece for three pawns and the white
king is out but Magnus he went down to
just about one or two seconds and barely
got his moves off so the I see the
evaluation White white is favored that
is clear but it's still within that
drawing territory for Magnus he is mad
but FV is locked in trying to find a way
to go after the black king or maybe to
checkm on the back rank was to WR a
queen Sacrifice from
Vladimir W that was beautiful let's just
back try very quickly one move Rook
takes Queen was not a good idea because
white would have landed a back ranker a
back spanker here that would have been
Checkmate so quen G5 he's going for the
end game Magnus Carson to take or not to
take what do we think should he keep the
Queens on the
board it's a tough one do you try to
attack Black's King on the queen side
where do you find the entry point he
decides not to trade moves are coming in
fast and
quick fast here White's King is weak so
normally you would want to trade off
Queens but fed needs to win he cannot
risk the Game fizzling out towards a
draw again Magnus begging for the queen
trade and uh he's still fighting
evaluation B say only small Advantage
here for white it's all about the pawns
Robert he's lacking pawns right now and
great understanding no surprise there
from Magnus Carlson if the Queens come
off he says I can hold because a pawn
chain is as strong as its base Pawn
without the Queens on the board it's
difficult for white to make inroad so we
see another queen trade being offered
but Magnus does need to be a bit careful
there could be a moment where he offers
a queen trade at an inopportune time and
thus allows white to transition into a
nearly winning ending so for now he
everything under control Tanya I don't
see how white makes progress
here well he's moving the king he's
saying I want to trade on my terms where
the king will find a nice spot on D4 the
good news for fos it's very hard for
Magnus to get rid of the C5 and the A3
pawns as long as the pawns are on the
board white will have good winning
chances the king is advancing from A5 to
B6 locking down magnus's Rook on on the
eighth rank to stop checkmating ideas
Magnus can't allow White's King to be
six steps up with The Rook one pawns
picked up I think fedos is going to get
the job done in this one I see the
evalar is equal but David practically
it's it's got to be really difficult to
hold got to be difficult to hold but the
big question does Magnus Carson believe
in fortresses we've heard the answer a
million times he originally said no but
he he is relying on one right now the
black king stops the white king from
coming in and uh if you hold your line
maybe it's tough okay a check now trying
to deflect the white king away he's
trading pawns he's getting the job done
Magnus I was agreeing Tanya I thought
white had great winning chances but not
against an endgame Genius Like Magnus
Carson suddenly black is getting closer
and closer to safety all he needs to do
is eliminate the remaining white porn
from the board and uh Robert it looks
like he's done everything right Magnus
although fedos sa still has chances
because we do know that if all three of
Black come off we well there's no way
fedos is going to make a draw by
repetition here he he's going to play on
until the very end because he does have
in extra pie so yes rook and Bishop
versus Rook everyone theoretical draw
but when you have no time on the clock
good luck to save it but for now I mean
Magnus is not giving any ground
David building up time on the clock as
well Magnus had one or two seconds a
while back suddenly Magnus is up at 15
16 seconds he's really up the pace
really upped his game and fed he'll R
another missed opportunity if this one
slips away he won a piece he tricked
Magnus in that time scramble but
suddenly look at the black Rook just uh
lining up pinning or attacking harassing
the white pieces and okay we see the
final white Pawn disappear so this is a
draw even if black loses his remaining
two pawns but that is difficult and the
black king is caught on the edge of the
board so there will be checkmating
patterns um let's predict now will
Magnus hold it might be difficult but
will he do
it I'm going to predict a big yes on
this one I mean what the position was
and what he's managed to get just his
resourcefulness in this end game has
been just incredible to watch putting
that King on A7 it felt like a fortress
then at the right time managing to
exchange trade off those remaining white
pawns and now for FV he's got to try to
push this position but Magnus has enough
time on the clock Robert I'm predicting
this one to end in a draw what about you
and of course should be a draw but look
at what fedos say is doing magnus's King
is caught on the side of the board and
if Magnus ever has to push his pawns
then those pawns become weaker Magnus
looks bored he's like I can do this in
my sleep but what fedos of he's
determined and this could be uh type of
position where white does get the upper
hand takes one Pawn then the second and
then you have to prove it over 50 turns
for everyone at home a 50 moves without
a capture or a pawn push results in a
draw and that's what Magnus is relying
on in fact when was the last Pawn push
does anyone
know a long time ago we'll go back and
count I think the last capture was a
bunch of moves ago 1520 moves already so
Magnus is getting closer it's the old
Captain America line I could do this all
day he's defending really uh resolutely
here and he's got his King off the edge
of the board look at this diamond
formation the black pawns and King here
um but going to hold these pawns
together that's for sure F say he's got
a few more moves Robert as you mentioned
he's got to win one of the black pawns
or push them forward force them provoke
them forward in order to keep the game
alive he's running out of time though
both on board and clock not making any
progress surely now as we reach 100
moves this one is edging closer to the
draw
so hard to beat Magnus Carlson it's
unbelievable it reminds me of the
Toronto finals where Magnus against
Fabby he was down a queen and he managed
to win that one and here he was down a
piece and it looked like f have did
everything to get his chances he strike
when it mattered and then eventually
Magnus just with his resourcefulness
manages to hold this end game the pawns
hav been moved one hasn't been captured
we are getting closer to the 50 move and
it looks like it might not even go into
a Rook Bishop was his Rook dare I say it
this is a fortress and there's been no
way for fedos to make progress because
the Rook on C4 it defends and prevents
the white king from joining the party so
what a hold from Magnus but what play
from fedos he should hold his head high
even if this game ends as a draw and he
goes down to the losers bracket because
if one little move went differently he
could have tied this match and maybe if
a couple things had gone a different way
he would have tied it earlier and had
some different
chances count down begins 10 more moves
10 moves to get to the 50 move Ru and it
will be a draw unless white wins a pawn
or one of the black pawn moves Tanya I
think he's wow just before it happens PA
Why did Magnus break the formation he
got impatient on the brink of a
draw that was a bad choice do it he just
had deat more moves to go he's making
his moves with half a second on his clap
look at his time he's barely getting his
moves and he's dropping his
pawns and Magnus knows it he's not happy
with his decisions one Pawn goes the 50
move has been reset and fedos chances
are
back just as we were saying he's on the
brink of a draw it was the 10 move
countdown if he did nothing for 10 moves
it would have been over by now but it's
the clock it was the Panic it was uh
just that Restless desire to do
something the human nature and now
suddenly this black porn in the center
is not going to survive that much longer
it might get
coralled it might get surrounded at some
point the black king will be driven away
still a lot of work to be done but now
fed he's going to be gaining in
confidence look at Magnus you're right
Robert just every move he's getting off
with two three seconds left he's really
feeling the nerves now he's only Human
After
All another song lyric dropped in there
from David I appreciate you but I think
that the white king it needs to get
active and Magnus still doing a good job
of keeping the white king Tethered to
the bishop not allowing it to cross the
the third ranks satanya I mean the move
counter it started again on move 117 we
are currently on move
138 are we going to see that pawn drop
off or is Magnus going to be able to
hold this position and not allow any
more trades he's got to try and do it
but it was really surprising how he let
the move counter reset with that move d4
lost the pawn FV has to look for his
chances to win that D4 pawn and then try
and fight it in a rook Bishop versus
Rook the main idea is to put push
magnus's King into some kind of a mating
net but step one has to be to grab that
D4 Pawn but the first question how do
you even bring the king out of that
second rank uh situation that Magnus has
trapped it into David do you see
progress for white king here I see
progress with a helping hand but
unfortunately again you're playing
Magnus Carson and he is a Marathon Man
whoa lost on time are you kidding
me no way
oh
my goodness Magnus Carlson gets
flagged unbelievable
fedos gets it done he gets the dub he
comes back it goes into armagedon I am
in utter disbelief but persistence pays
off for fedos I know Magnus represents
Mission zero but he didn't want 0
seconds on his clock it is 2 to2 Magnus
he went away but he has another game to
play all of a sudden I cannot believe
that Magnus carlsson just lost on time
it reminds me of his final game in the
uh Champions chestor as world champion
against aaro Nakamura where he moused up
his Queen how can this possibly happen
to the best player on the
planet this is on real we're all reeling
in from this while Dennis lazovic
advances through Magnus Carlson has got
to fight it down in the armagon Magnus
Carlson getting flagged you don't get to
see that David I'm out of words I think
we all need a quick break before this
armag gon starts we will have the bids
really soon Magus needs to recover we
all need to recover don't go anywhere
we'll be back in just a
[Music]
few
you're on a train or on a plane or you
go completely off grid with chessable
offline mode you can now study chess
anytime anywhere and not miss a day of
training and when you're back online you
just synchronize and everything is
updated
automatically
we're going to play blindfold blitz so
I'm actually going to get up right now
and I'm going to blindfold him all right
this is you know nothing weird is going
to happen here trust me you go close
your eyes right I'm going to move the
pieces for you so all you got to do is
just say the move and I'm going to move
the pieces for him I'm going to start
your clock you just say your move and
hit your clock so okay play one B3 okay
okay so he plays B3 I'm going to play
Knight F6 Bishop
B2
G6 Knight
F3 Bishop G7
C4 C4 yep he got a good position all
right Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4
check Knight to F6 Queen E3 I think
you're doing great just so you if you're
worried I thought it looks like a very
boring
position why am I struggling so much
with the right thing to play here um my
plan now is just to try to flag You
Queen to V6 yeah I good move I have 2
minutes and 24 seconds you have 4
minutes and 45 seconds maybe I should
have given you 10
minutes all right I know I know I'm old
and slow you're not 4
to all right I'm going play Rook to d8
I'll play
Rook
fd1 you play a lot of good chest moves I
never told you
that no h hold a freaking draw here come
on di all right Rook takes D1 yeah Rook
takes
Rook I got to do what I need to do to
win you got to do what you got to do to
win got to respect it Knight to F6 ah
what are you doing you training
something I was like uh King to
E3 why did you have to see it it was
one Rook to D Rook to D1 D D1 yeah I
feel you Daddy okay
ah I'll play rope to
C4 okay Bishop to
D5 I play Fe
three Wes see this is your chance to
blend you can do it Rook to G1 mhm Bush
A5 no more mate Rook to G1 bone to
E4 oh man was an accurate move Bishop to
a
B7 okay I'm just kidding I let go on A8
I can't do it I can't take advantage of
a blind
man I'm getting M it I'm getting made it
King to G7 oh why why are you running
that was a good move by me it's not over
yet Knight E8
check I'm going to play the most boring
King to
F7 Arrow takes Bishop a it Wesley yeah
King takes
E8 King
E King to f8 all King to
F6 oh wow that hurts actually that's a
big time oh I lost on time that was a
make I lost track of time wow good game
I almost feel okay okay about myself
almost yeah you're doing good for your
first game after a long time than
yeah
welcome to the most exciting format in
chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black in those coveted
draw ODS let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence
in just a few seconds we will have the
Armageddon and the bids are in Magnus
Carlson wins the bid he did go pretty
low with 6 minutes 38 seconds Vladimir
fedia with an 8 minute 3 second bid to
me it looks like David that FV was happy
to get white he did not want to
compromise too much on the time
understandably he just struck with white
he won with the white and now he has a
few extra minutes in his pocket Magnus
meanwhile that's a brave brave bid How
Low Can You Go 6 and a half is living
life on the edge especially because he
knows now feder has that recipe of
creating Chaos on the board for better
or worse that last game fed Sav he
showed how to do
it and Robert fedos flagged Magnus but
he had the upper hand throughout the
game he was the one who was pushing
after the Miss in the middle game by
Magnus and let's not forget game two as
well it felt like fedf should have got
the D this is going to be a big fight
we're off and we're seeing a repeat it's
the Queen's Gambit decline this time
well there are a few things that we
can't forget as the players they
shouldn't forget their opening lines FV
he is the world rapid silver medalist
behind Magnus Carlson he also can play
very long games he doesn't just end them
on the spot so when is Armageddon
without increment he start to worry
about the clock so fed is using time as
a weapon Magnus he hasn't moved David
can you actually afford to invest this
kind of time at this stage of the game
when you're playing Vladimir
FV you simply cannot you need to adapt
you need to react you need to just trust
your instincts and Magnus actually
sacrifices a pawn big decision here if
this Pawn is captured the Black Knight
jumps into the B4 Square not only is the
Black Knight coming in Via C2 in that
variation but the White Queen might have
been trapped so wisely avoiding the
Temptation greed not being good in this
case but uh you're right Magnus it feels
again right now that he's freezing he
hasn't adapted kind of to this new
Rhythm that he needs we've I mean I've
played Armageddon we've all seen
Armageddon games it's all about the
speed you need to at least get out of
the traps the early stages the opening
middle game in good shape on the clock
Magna still has under six minutes now um
but it's going to get scary especially
if white starts throwing pawns forward
this might be the opportunity for fed go
for the black king complicated because
complicated positions are the hardest to
navigate in time trouble he does it g
he's going with the the points now
towards the black king Tanya this is
scary for Magnus already G4 H4 on the
board you're down by more than three and
a half minutes on the clock and the game
is just getting started when the king is
under Fire no increment this can get
really out of hand very quick for Magnus
I'd already be scared with this move G5
coming in Magnus jumps in with the
Knight but can white still think about
sacrificing a Pawn on the king side and
he does it he wants to open the hline
the queen is headed to H5 if black
starts getting greedy and this is why
the uh you see the blue arrow F6 the
only move to keep the balance for Magnus
Carlson and he doesn't find it I mean
that's not an easy move to play pushing
Pawns in front of your own King he
actually allows the capture of a Pawn on
H6 but then white would have had a
sacrifice material on C3 so look at
fed's response David a natural play by
him defending his Knight but it was a
mistake a missed opportunity and now
Magnus finds that correct choice he said
AB he s he said H and G with his pawns
he needed to just continue the attack
just hammer away at the black king but
now it's too late now black is the one
striking uh on the king side because
actually all of Black's pieces are in
play this Knight now hit but Black's
Bishop x-ray vision against the king
Black's Bishop from afar the light
Bishop as well doing a great job and
this centralized Knight suddenly he's
lost momentum here fed and that's how
quickly things can turn around suddenly
black is the one with the open file
looking at the white king um I agree
Robert it was almost imperceptible blink
and you miss it but that one chance the
question mark or the missed opportunity
we saw from fed suddenly things are
turning and Magnus at least his moves
are flowing he's really picked up that
pace in the last few moves sudden he's
down to a three minute time Advantage
only for FV and what a mess we have in
front of us Tanya this is the definition
of a real melee but with white that's
exactly what you want you want a mess in
the position when you're playing against
Magnus it is about those one move
opportunity fedy have missed it now
Magnus taking his Queen out also
thinking about doubling up on the F line
with the Rook watch out once Rook from
A8 comes to f8 there might be sacrifices
on the bishop on F4 Rook takes Bishop
idea is always in the air to me it just
looks like Black's the one who's on the
attack right now and for fed that King
is going to be stuck in the center for
the rest of the game well that sounds
familiar to me because that's exactly
what happened a game ago right Magnus
was able to go after some a weak King he
was able to get his Rooks involved and
yet fedos of still was surviving and
then won so this is a bad position for
white the king is in the center the
black king isn't that unsafe despite
white taking all his time to pry openen
the G file so Magnus he does need to be
careful here because the queen was
staring at his King on G8 and that's why
he kicks that Queen back and is going to
force it to square like G2 a little bit
more passive Anton I love your idea of
doubling Rooks and David I feel like as
we look at this position where's the
attack for white I actually think that
black is the one more likely to have the
attack against the white king totally
agree if this was anyone else other than
fed I would say this is really backfired
it's really gone wrong but he has such a
wrigly style fed I've played him many
times myself he escapes from these weird
positions these awkward looking
positions with all the pieces hanging
he's so good at quick calculation two
three move lines he knows if he doesn't
blunder anything he'll get chances later
on and uh it's like being a sportsman
sometimes you just have to get through a
game and take your chance when you might
only get one or two shots uh just pounce
a bit later as he did in the previous
game in the must-win situation so now
Magnus under four minutes no
increment I starting to believe in fed's
chances even if the white king looks a
bit awkward in the center these piece
trades don't necessarily help black and
they're only going to make uh the game
drag on a bit longer take this bishop
back with the queen why not and then uh
yeah I'm not sure where the white king
is going but then try to line up at
least pose questions as magnus's clock
ticks down who do you think is the
favorite
Armageddon it's only ramping up pressure
now it's such a difficult question and
David while it felt like objectively you
should keep the pieces on the board but
given magnus's time now under four
minutes no increment he's just trying to
ease off the pressure trying to ease the
complications off but I think that only
helps fed like you pointed out it was a
lot harder for the white king as long as
there were more pieces but with these
trades it looks like fedf can breathe a
bit more the bishop falls back to D6 six
I like the idea of Rook G1 but again you
always have to watch out for Rook to f8
Rook F4 sacrifices perhaps at some point
Magnus is also eyeing that knight from
A5 suddenly jumping on to C4 with that
last move Bishop D6 it x-rays that
Knight on E5 with the bishop on F4 the
more I look at it I think Knight C4 is a
threat on the board well you know what I
was thinking that Bishop G5 If This Were
a bullet game that's what I'm playing
from the white side I'm pinning your
Rook on F6 and I'm just trying to open
the H file and go after the black king I
don't think it works considering the
evaluation bar is still saying black has
the better position but if it did work
it would say white is winning and ho do
I I know my man Vladimir F he's going
for it he's going for it and we also
know Magnus Carson he will not allow an
attack unless he can calculate his way
through and he actually doesn't play the
best move we saw Miss wow a blunder now
Magnus Carlson I was going to say he
just takes back the pawn sacrifices The
Exchange but what has he missed can
white ignore the threat on this Rook
this looked like a hit but if you ignore
and go for the black Rook instead he
moves it Bishop takes Rook I think was
winning there and going for the black
king wow we might show that a bit later
but Magnus dodged a bullet still in
trouble though as now the bishop lands
on this Square watch out for the Rook
lining up the queen jumping in magnus's
King is living life on the edge it's
been left abandoned by its own Queen The
Black Queen so far offside now T you
think he's just going to check mate
Magnus it's insane how many donor ons
we're seeing in this matchup it's just
hard to predict anything and suddenly it
looks like white is once again on the
attack David I think the idea that you
were earlier alluding to give up your
Rooks go for that Bishop F6 Queen G6 but
it's still in the air Queen G6 is coming
up next how is Magnus fighting it the
queen from A3 cannot come back into the
defense the E7 square is controlled by
the bishop Queen G6 I think Rook F7 is
the defensive resource here but things
looking very dangerous for Magnus he
decides to give up his exchange I think
it's a good try I mean I think for
Magnus this is what David was suggesting
earlier and only one move keeps the edge
for fedos of Rook G6 the move does make
a lot of sense that black Rook is both a
defender of the king and also an
aggressive piece Queen D4 can hardly fa
fedos for this and now Queen E7 I see
the arrows coming in that's an only move
but I think that only move is Pretty
Natural for black to play bring more
pieces to your King's defense though
that A7 Pawn is also lose I don't really
know how both these players are
assessing the position equal doesn't
feel
accurate to me it looks like draw is the
least likely result in this one this is
absolute Madness so it doesn't matter
what the evalar says yes you can grab
the A7 Pawn but that would give Magnus
the time to bring his Knight into play
once that Knight jumps to C4 D I think
Magnus can start looking for tricks on
White's King suddenly this Black Knight
sitting on a beautiful Outpost is going
to be worth just as much as one of the
white Rooks this Rook on C2 not
participating at all um so yeah
definitely turning around fed to say if
he doesn't know he missed an opportunity
but there was a big one and suddenly
anyone's game the Knight lands on C4
will he prize open the position risk it
uh by pushing his pawns forward in the
center fed he wants to open up the white
Rooks but it might also open up his King
you can see on the cameras fed leaning
in now he knows it's about to become a
Time scramble Magna still two whole
minutes down two and a half minutes with
zero increment we've all play Blitz
online on chess.com it is scary it might
come down to flagging and fed look he's
just preparing a nice home for the white
king he's getting ready for the long
game a bit of a maneuvering battle later
he's trying to prolong uh this one as
much as possible but a night fork in the
air uh Robert who are you favoring here
evaluation bar giving us no clues at all
the knights are trickier pieces so from
the board position I actually like
Black's chances but it's about the clock
fedos with the white pieces to start
with mag with his low bid sure the
deficit has been trimmed but this is
scary territory when there's opponent's
rook and queen lined up against your
king and watch out for Pawn breaks
that's what Magnus is trying to avoid
and I love his last couple moves routing
the night stopping the the breaks But
Here Come trade offers and can you
afford to liquidate too much if the
Queen's come off the board is white
winning is black So within the drawing
range Tanya these are difficult
questions maybe nearly impossible
questions to answer unless you could sit
and think for instead of 20 seconds 20
minutes and has Magnus has been flagged
once today will he be flagged twice I
like that decision by Magnus though it
means you keep more pieces on the board
but taking on F4 would have opened up
the E Line attacking that Queen giving a
lot of activity to the white Rook as
well the Knight jumps back Knights are
tricky I'm going to put both of you on a
spot here if you had to predict a result
and outcome of this Armageddon what do
you think is going to happen David I'm G
to stop with you I think Magnus takes it
just because of the trickiness of the
Black Knight but the clock situation
makes it a bit hairy right now how about
you Robert well I like the clock for
fedos so I think that based on what we
saw in the previous game I am going to
say that fedos has good chances is he
the favorite uh who can make that
prognostication but I do think that his
legit chances and I mean I'm like Rook
G4 right now can black actually swap
Rooks I fed plays it and Magnus quickly
answers he is keeping the Rooks on the
board he wants more material on because
he's not sure how to evaluate the end
game yeah yeah if I had to predict I'm
going to predict a big win for big fish
in this one it just looks like with a
minute and a half on the clock and a
tricky position Queens on the board this
is going to be a tough one for Magnus
so wow big moment big moment though I
think he's blundered big fish he needed
to walk out of some Forks the computer
gives it away the Blue Arrow Pawn to C5
and white is defenseless the White Queen
there would have been caught in two
minds he's played it in a different
order same idea with a draw up his
sleeve I think this is good enough
Magnus now he's threatening all sorts if
the White Queen moves there'll be
tactics like Rook takes Pawn in the air
the white Rook here undermined on G4 the
white king is actually a Target the
black pieces combining
now might have it Magnus Carson still
some calculation to be done Robert what
about this what has just happened it's a
travesty for fosa because trading off
Queens here even though Magnus had more
he's like look at this end game we have
even material at least I'll put that in
quotes because black kind of looks like
he's up a pawn or two because all of
White's isolated in double Pawn so bnus
is not going to lose this game unless FV
can flag him but that seems unlikely
given how easy it is for Black's move so
Tanya you've you asked the question I'm
gonna pass it back to you any chance for
feda because of the
time I gave you my prediction I mean
with the Queens on the board just three
moves ago I felt like this is going to
be a tough save for Magnus but now with
the trades that we're seeing in fact
Magnus is the one who can push FAL look
at the pawn structure the B Pawn move
moving forward the king will be a nice
one on that E6 square a minute on the
clock that's more than enough once the
Queens are traded off am I allowed to
change my
predictions wow Magnus gives up his Rook
if Rook takes Rook the black porn would
have just promoted would have walked
down the board beautiful tactics
awareness there from Magnus Carson he's
w a porn he's going to save this game
surely 53 seconds he's a great bullet
player he should have enough this black
seor should win the game let L A draw so
Robert needs a miracle now fough he's
just given away his porn Magnus Kelson
why I wasn't sure if he was pre-moving
but he does have plenty of time and this
is a position where if you just talk
about the chess there's no chance white
ever lose it but or black lose excuse me
but when you look at the clock fed is
going to try to pressure him but there's
no way out you just force the checks if
the Rooks come off the board then the
last Pawn drops and that's immediately a
draw and if you get the king closer to
the Rook The Rook goes to A2 and you can
defend the a pawn I think a really great
practical Choice by Magnus to give back
that pawn and then to just trade off
into everything 35 seconds but David
that's more than enough in this position
more than enough but I like what fed is
doing flagging is encouraged here who
cares about morals just flag the
opponent this his last chance 30 seconds
but it is a repetition Magnus progresses
from this Armageddon wow it was so close
so close what a match what a fight by f
he lost early on in the match but made a
comeback took it into Armageddon and
what an Armageddon this was in the end
Magnus Carlson advances into the
Winner's final and will be taking on
Dennis Laz for FV Robert he's got a lot
of reasons to be proud of the fight he
put up today he barely lost this match
yes he goes down to the losers bracket
where he'll await some of the top guns
but you saw that on his face he just
looked clicked on game review and fedos
say was like oh no I missed the tactic
so he is you know had his chances he
should be proud of it but you could see
it there he's like I I just wasn't
looking in that direction it looked too
scary he did have an opportunity and he
may kick himself later for
that just unreal stuff and was a big
opportunity in fact fosf could have
grabbed the victory at a moment David
what a miss that was we have to rewind
and show in slow motion what he could
have done fed have just had one move
opportunity to win this game to pretty
much knock Magnus down to the losers
bracket but unfortunately no time on the
clock he did miss it and it was
difficult so I think he should forgive
himself fed and we can forgive him but
if we get an opportunity I would love to
show that moment as
fed unfortunately got uh got tricked
into that end game Magnus was just too
strong but it was here after Magnus had
actually made a big mistake a grave
error Queen to A3 hitting this white
Rook fed reacted but he should not have
trusted the world number one he should
have ignored the threat Bishop takes
Rook this is a beautiful tactic
reminiscent of the Romantic ages of
Chess where you give up one Rook with
check you give up a second rook and if
black now takes this Rook you simply
create a big threat Queen takes H1 and
queen to G6 there's actually no more
checks no way to defend the G7 Square
either white despite being down a rook
delivers check made so this opportunity
was in the position he missed it and
therefore gets knocked down to the
losers bracket
FV almost had the win against the world
number one game two so close he gets the
job done in game four it was flagging
but it happened and then in the
Armageddon as well but Magnus Carlson
just so hard to beat he keeps going in
the winnner bracket and these are our
score lines the 17-year-old Dennis lavic
did not need a game four to get the dub
in he wraps up his match in just three
games against Jose Martinez it's going
to be Dennis laic against Magnus Carlson
tomorrow Robert David I'd love to get
your thoughts looking ahead into this
match between The Clash of
generations well Magnus he said I'll
play Ali Raza for world championship and
no one else but we have other teenagers
on the scene alriza no longer a teenager
himself but Dennis lvic the 17-year-old
he beat Hikaru he beat Anish he beat
Maxim Vash gr and then he beat the other
Underdog in Jose Martinez so why not
Miracles sometimes they do happen and
why not for Dennis lazic who plays the
best player in chess history the best
player of the last decade at the very
least Magnus Carlson hey the the magic
can continue for the
youngster I agree Dennis lazic unbeaten
so far in division one bringing his best
game today was uh very smooth for Dennis
a bit up and down meanwhile for his
opponent tomorrow Magnus so that one
anyone's game but of course the losers
uh quarter finals as well that is going
to be fascinating to watch as those two
players Martinez and FV still have one
life
left absolutely David two more players
will be eliminated of the chville
Masters tomorrow big big fights coming
up uh right now we are going to be
joined very soon with our guest don't go
anywhere we will be back with an
interview what a day it's
been
[Music]
it's crazy oh my God I don't feel it yet
because there's so much spice already in
my mouth TR thermost up please no milk
no milk no fing milk James I'm going to
go to the
ambulance what's up everyone chess as
hard as it is but we're about to make it
even harder by playing chili chest for
every type of piece we capture we are
going to eat a chip with some hot sauce
on it starting with the pawns Knights
Bishops and Rooks a queen and then the
loser of the game is going to eat this
drenched chip over here ready to go
yeah and here we
go oh man we battled a lot in the it's
like you letting me take it bro we we
get inant you must be hungry bro I'm too
scared to capture take it bro no no no
no cuz then we have to eat the you know
what now you got to eat the freaking
chip all so
big yes oh
man it feels like I'm inhaling a
barbecue I hate that one that's pretty
good that is the official turn buddy
beautiful that one's weird man it's like
citrusy but like correct kind of tastes
like you know what that's exactly what
it would taste like I'm rolling up my we
got the end game with the chips
the this is which one do I want okay
none of you back wait I like how silent
psychological battle nobody's drank milk
yet right we like
okay all right word looks different when
you high on
spice oh man that boy hitting
different ship's kind of hot to be Shing
like
that this definitely getting hot in this
room guys you
didn't turny to thermostat up oh I took
I took a pawn Mister oh you took a pond
you did damn bro you catching
everything oh got check oh my God time
no oh my
God okay so the problem is I don't feel
it yet because there's so much spice
already in my mouth so it's probably
going to be like how Magnus said creeps
up on you yeah now it's turning creep up
I feel it I feel it oh man I'm going to
go to the
ambulance I'm going to call the people
right now now my hand please no milk no
milk no milk we doing this with no milk
noing milk James so two brothers we in a
ditch somewhere yeah explosions all
around no milk we ask when I'm you need
a Band-Aid no I need no milk sir no
milk I'm going to feel that for a few
days few hours I did bro I did I did but
you your brain don't work right with all
the spices and stuff no man I can't feel
my
fingers same time next week
say sure that's a
date
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
cheser Masters where we are joined by
one of today's winners Magnus Carson and
Magnus first of all congratulations but
what are your first uh thoughts on how
today
went uh yeah the games are pretty
terrible in general
I mean that's not a new take coming for
me but uh yeah that was
um yeah that was not good
but well I prevailed that was more or
less the only good thing but
uh
I yeah just everything was was bad and
my brain was just not working so I'll
have to be a bit better I think coming
up how did you feel that your opponent
Vladimir fed have played did you feel
that tday was terrible because of how
tough he made it for you or was it just
uh on both
sides no he has a style which is kind of
uncomfortable like he plays very
ambitiously and sometimes makes
nontraditional positional
decisions um which is rather difficult
to face when you're not at your at your
best so it has something to do with his
play as well uh for sure but if I'd had
a good day I don't think it would have
been would have been as close as it was
and honestly I mean with with a little
bit of uh Precision he could have pulled
out this this
much uh we were curious in game four it
looked like uh a Time round in the end
was it just kind of a moment of freezing
or what happened
there yeah I just said
like my brain was just fried at that
point and I I couldn't I couldn't think
like I couldn't in my head even remember
like I wasn't even confident that I was
going to hold rook and Bishop against
Rook while if I feel normal I feel that
even with a few seconds that shouldn't
be
that shouldn't be an issue so I was just
I was just you know going through the
motions like hoping for the game to end
and then I was choosing the defensive
setup I tried to make a move but I my
movements weren't crisp either um so
yeah that's what
happened and uh it's a new season a new
time control just 10 minutes plus two
seconds this time um how confident were
you about that Armageddon bid you made
uh what was it around 6 minutes and a
bit yeah I saw that that's um
approximately what Maxim B so I thought
he generally has thought about these
things he knows what he's doing so let
me do the same so you've been watching
our show or at least watching the other
games yeah I am a chess fan
so nice to hear nice to get confirmation
and um we do have a few questions from
our chat and one from Krishna
21234 uh Krishna is asking given that
you're playing from a new location do
you think familiarity with the
surroundings or lack thereof uh is
affecting your playing
style um I probably should have gotten a
bigger monitor um that probably would
help apart from that I don't think it
matters too
much konix asks uh Magnus were you
thrown off by fet sa
speed no I'm I'm used to this style from
from
fedf um this is the way he this is the
way he plays in general like sometimes
he plays a bit better sometimes he plays
a bit worse um but he he always makes it
difficult for you
by um by playing fighting
non-traditional uh
Jaz
uh Magnus just before we let you go I
have to ask about tomorrow's winnner
final um or sorry the winnner final at
least against Dennis lazic how are you
feeling about that one how impressed are
you so far with his
run am I not playing
tomorrow I that was my bad uh the
winners final when it comes around
against denn
laic I'm not trying to trick you
this no um I mean certainly not easy
um I mean he's been he played really
well last season even in Toronto in the
final he was very
competitive and um I mean this time he's
really defeated a murderer row of uh
players just to get here
so yeah certainly not easy
and I have to up my game a bit cuz today
was uh will probably not be good good
enough
tomorrow I have just got confirmation
you are playing tomorrow so what will
you do to
[Music]
prepare uh I don't know probably not too
much to be honest um some openings
though just don't blame me if you forget
to turn up tomorrow it is in fact
happening I can confirm uh Magnus
congratulations today I'm going to let
you go now get some rest start preparing
those openings and uh many
congratulations see you tomorrow thank
you David see
you see and uh there we had it Magnus
Carson defeating Vladimir fedf uh not
too happy with his play but getting the
job done and tomorrow against Dennis Las
T yeah what a match we had today and
it's going to be quite the Fin's final
tomorrow as the 17-year-old Dennis laek
who is in such great form he's been
playing phenomenal chess takes on the
ultimate test against the world number
one Magnus Carlson I'm really glad that
you told Magnus that he's got to play
tomorrow David he might not have shown
up
otherwise I was pretty sure but then he
I don't know he made me doubt myself and
then I backed down and oh poor
Magnus he's got bad influences around
him trust me David you were like fedos
over there you trusted Magnus a little
bit too much you know you should have
been firm with him and let him know that
you were correct in in this
position next time
that's shows up he will show up and
we're going to have a great winner final
but Robert it was also so interesting to
see that Magnus was critical about his
match despite winning it yeah he is an
honest objective assessor of his own
play he really is happy when he feels
like he truly played a brilliant game
and he's unhappy when he feels like
there were improvements that he should
have spotted but it's funny because his
not best effort is still good enough he
makes it through to the winners finals
unlike some of our other players who had
to say goodbye to the tournament as
their run ended today yeah and two more
we'll say goodbye tomorrow but let's
take a look at where we stand at the
chessel Masters and these are the
standings Maxim bashra Wesley so with
losses today are out of the tournament
and they get the paycheck uh coming
their way the meanwhile the others
continue and the Fight Continues and the
winner will get a spot into the season
and final lot more chess coming up David
what was the highlight for you in
today's matches well I've got to say the
incredible Checkmate we saw earlier
today it feels like a lifetime ago now
but yanomi delivering checkmate with a
queen sacrifice fuja Landing some nice
sacrifices of his own and then that
Armageddon that one with Magnus Carson
and FV we didn't know who was going to
win until right near the end till the
last few seconds it was fast it was fun
and uh ultimately Magnus prevailed
yeah and I'm gonna give the floor to you
one more time before we sign off for the
day what was the what impressed you
today so much impressed me I mean we saw
blunders we saw brilliancies and we just
saw people fighting their hearts out two
players had to leave the tournament but
even though he didn't win his match I
have to give a shout to Vladimir fedos
he proves each and every match that he
is a worthy Contender yesterday he
stormed back from a death to take down
oi Raza fuia today he gave Magnus
Carlson everything he could handle and
was oh so close to Knocking the number
one player in the world down to the
losers bracket so I would say that lavic
continues to shine he beat that
murderous row as Magnus called it Magnus
himself he's always impressive but then
I would say third honors go to Vladimir
F because yeah he was Stellar even in
defeat and he will be back tomorrow in
the losers bracket fighting on his last
life but what a performance by him today
against the world number one trustable
Masters continues into a big big day
tomorrow in the elimination bracket and
in the winners final today was a day of
heartbreaks and celebration lots of
twists and turns what big moments we've
had it's been a dramatic day chat we
will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
he
a
[Music]
yeah
oh
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
w